chers collègues messieurs les ministres
la séance est reprise l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion du projet de loi
rejeté par l'Assemblée nationale après
engagement de la procédure accélérée de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2023 à 2027 dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général monsieur
le ministre chez Gabriel Attal mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
je m'exprime devant vous dans un
contexte économique difficile
marqué par de fortes incertitudes
des incertitudes géopolitiques d'abord
liées à la guerre en Ukraine
les incertitudes fortes liées à la
politique protectionniste de certains de
nos partenaires
je pense à la Chine
je pense aux États-Unis avec une
fléchienne peu d'action Act qui
aujourd'hui pèse sur nos industries sur
nos implantations industrielles
les incertitudes liées également à la
forte volatilité des prix du gaz qui
après avoir été multipliée par 5 ou 10 à
baissé de près de 50% en quelques
semaines
mais ce qui touche évidemment le plus le
compatriotes avant ces incertitudes
géopolitiques c'est l'inflation qui en
résulte
l'inflation a atteint des niveaux
inédits depuis 40 ans dans l'Union
européenne et je voudrais que chacun
d'entre nous à travers notre débat
prenne conscience de la réalité de
l'inflation dans les autres pays
européens
22% dans les pays baltes
17% au Pays-Bas
11% en Allemagne
si pour son inflation en France est
toujours trop mais je rappelle que c'est
le chiffre le plus bas de la zone euro
je rappelle que la France résiste mieux
que nos voisins à l'inflation grâce au
choix stratégiques qui étaient faits en
octobre 2021 de mettre en place un
bouclier énergétique sur le gaz et sur
l'électricité grâce à ce choix
stratégique la France a aujourd'hui le
taux d'inflation le plus faible de tous
les pays de la zone euro
la France résiste aussi économiquement
nous avons réalisé 0,2 points de
croissance au troisième trimestre 2022
l'investissement des entreprises
a progressé de 2,3% contre 0,8 % au
deuxième trimestre il continue donc de
progresser notamment dans l'aéronautique
dans l'automobile et dans l'informatique
je ne sous-estime donc pas les
difficultés économiques mais je ne
voudrais pas que nous sédions au
pessimisme ou à l'autoflagellation
notre économie dépend des circonstances
internationales mais pas seulement elle
dépend aussi notre détermination de la
stabilité des choix de politique
économique que nous avons fait depuis
près de 6 ans et que je rappellerai tout
à l'heure et de notre vision de long
terme d'une économie compétitive
innovante et décarbonée
dans les circonstances actuelles notre
priorité celle qui figure dans le projet
de loi de finances c'est de protéger nos
compatriotes contre l'inflation et de
faire baisser cette inflation pour la
ramener dans les meilleurs délais
possibles à un niveau plus raisonnable
comment pouvons-nous y parvenir
d'abord c'est la première nécessité
absolue en garantissant la bonne
coordination de la politique monétaire
et de la politique budgétaire nous ne
pouvons pas avoir une politique
monétaire restrictive et une politique
budgétaire expansioniste c'est pourquoi
nous avons pris la décision avec la
première ministre de mettre en place des
aides ciblées pour les entreprises
contre l'augmentation des prix du gaz de
l'électricité 10 milliards d'euros
d'aide mais 10 milliards qui sont
intégralement financés soit par les 3
milliards du plan de résilience soit par
les 7 milliards d'euros de recettes
supplémentaires du prélèvement sur les
rentes inframmargiales des entreprises
énergéticiennes 10 milliards qui sont
plafonnés pour ne pas exposer le budget
de l'État à la volatilité des prix du
marché c'est une décision protectrice
mais c'est aussi une décision
responsable du point de vue des finances
publiques pour éviter la divergence
entre politique monétaire et politique
budgétaire
même chose au niveau européen où nous
devons coordonner nos réponses de
politiques budgétaires pour garantir des
niveaux de soutien comparables face à
l'inflation regardez ce qui s'est passé
en Grande-Bretagne qui doit nous servir
de leçon à tous tout n'est pas possible
et on peut toujours promettre à nos
compatriotes de dépenser 7 8 9 10% notre
PNB pour lutter contre l'inflation le
résultat c'est la sanction immédiate des
marchés l'envoler des taux d'intérêt et
la nécessité de revenir en arrière
nous nous préférons avec le président de
la République aller de l'avant
coordonner nos réponses de politique
budgétaire je rappelle que aujourd'hui
contrairement ce que j'entends trop
souvent dire les niveaux de soutien des
citoyens et des entreprises en France
sont parfaitement comparables à ceux des
autres grands pays de la zone euro de 4
à 5% du PNB sur la période 2021 2023
c'est cette coordination qui préserve la
force de notre réponse et qui évite une
fragmentation de la zone
en deuxième lieu c'est la deuxième
nécessité ce n'est pas la plus simple à
faire comprendre
et c'est la plus courageuse
et la plus responsable
c'est éviter la spirale inflationniste
qui avait été provoqué dans les années
1970 par une augmentation générale et
automatique des salaires totalement
découplés la productivité du travail
c'est très bien de promettre
l'indexation des salaires sur
l'inflation et je sais que beaucoup de
nos compatriotes aujourd'hui
souhaiteraient avoir des salaires plus
élevés
le président de la République a fermé la
porte à cette indexation générale je
crois profondément que cette décision
est courageuse
responsable et nous évitera bien des
déboires demain comme ceux que nous
avions connu dans les années 1970 car
l'indexation en général des salaires sur
les prix sont considération de
productivité du travail cela conduit à
une nouvelle réduction de la marge des
entreprises qui du coup serait obligé de
répercuter cette perte de marge sur
l'augmentation des prix à la
consommation c'est une spirale sans fin
d'augmentation des salaires à quelle
répondre une augmentation des prix et
nouvelle augmentation des salaires et
une nouvelle augmentation des prix c'est
cette spirale impressionniste dans
laquelle nous refusons en responsabilité
de rentrer
car nous serions perdants sur tous les
tableaux
nous aurions une inflation hors de
contrôle alors même que notre objectif
stratégique et de revenir à des niveaux
raisonnables d'inflation pour protéger
des plus modestes et protéger des
entreprises les plus fragiles
nous décrocherions en termes de
compétitivité au moment même ou grâce à
des efforts constants depuis plusieurs
années nous sommes en train de retrouver
notre compétitivité
enfin nous ruinions tous les efforts de
réindustrialisation qui ont donné des
résultats sur l'emploi
l'attractivité
l'investissement en France depuis 6 ans
est-ce que cela veut dire pour autant
que nous devrions abandonner l'idée
d'une meilleure rémunération du travail
certainement pas mais faisons la
différence entre les promesses
démagogiques d'un équation générale des
salaires sur les prix et le choix
responsable qui est celui de notre
majorité de garantir une meilleure
rémunération du travail cette meilleure
rémunération du travail elle passe
d'abord pour les salaires les plus
modestes par l'indexation qui existe du
SMIC qui je le rappelle a augmenté de 8%
en un an les salaires les plus modestes
sont donc protégés contre l'inflation
au delà je l'ai dit à de multiples
reprises depuis maintenant plus de trois
ans avant même que l'inflation ne
revienne les entreprises qui le peuvent
doivent augmenter les salaires
elles le font d'ailleurs quand vous
regardez les chiffres très largement
depuis plusieurs mois
il faut par ailleurs continuer à
travailler sur ce qui me paraît le vrai
débat le débat juste sur le meilleur
partage de la valeur entre capital et
travail c'est ça le véritable débat
quand nous poussons à l'intéressement
quand nous poussons à la participation
quand nous supprimons la taxe de 20% sur
l'intéressement quand nous facilitons la
conclusion d'un corps d'intéressement
pour les plus petites entreprises quand
nous mettons en place une prime
défiscalisée à 6000 euros quand nous
facilitons l'accès à l'actionnariat
salarié qui a fortement augmenté depuis
cinq ans qu’est-ce que nous faisons
d'autres si l'on garantir un meilleur
partage de la valeur entre le travail et
le capital au profit du travail voilà le
fil rouge de la meilleure rémunération
du travail voilà le vrai fil rouge la
justice sociale par de l'argent
distribué gratuitement mais de l'argent
qui est le fruit du travail de la
production et de la compétitivité
retrouver de nos entreprises
c'est pour cela que je souhaite qu'avec
les partenaires sociaux nous avançons
plus rapidement sur notre proposition de
dividendes salariés qui doit donner
rapidement des résultats concrets une
entreprise qui distribue des résultats à
ses actionnaires doit aussi distribuer
des salaires à ces employés voilà le
sens de ce dividende salarié qui était
proposé par le Président de la
République et qui est une nouvelle
illustration de notre volonté de mieux
partager la rémunération du travail et
du capital
la troisième réponse de long terme pour
lutter contre l'inflation au delà de la
coordination de la politique monétaire
de la politique budgétaire au-delà de la
rémunération du travail par un meilleur
partage de la valeur c'est
d'investissement de long terme dans
l'énergie
60% de l'inflation que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui est une inflation importée
qui est Dieu à la flambée des prix des
énergies fossiles qui représentent je le
rappelle encore deux tiers de la
consommation d'énergie dans notre pays
si nous voulons réduire l'inflation il
faut renforcer notre indépendance et
notamment notre indépendance énergétique
car nous nous y trompons pas cette
flambée d'inflation en Europe se traduit
par un transfert massif de richesse des
pays européens vers les pays producteurs
d'énergie fossile nous n'avons pas
vocation à financer les pays producteurs
d'énergie fossile nous avons vocation à
investir dans les renouvelables et dans
l'énergie nucléaire c'est exactement ce
qu'a proposé est décidé le président de
la République
enfin un budget ce sont aussi des
constantes qui font la force d'une
politique et c'est constant je vais les
réaffirmer ici même si je sais que nous
aurons dans les jours qui viennent un
vrai débat sur ces sujets
la première de constante c'est de
renforcement de l'appareil productif et
donc la baisse des impôts
je connais les doutes qui se sont
manifestés dans cette assemblée nous
avons discuté avec un certain nombre de
président de groupe à l'égard d'une
nouvelle baisse des impôts de production
notamment la suppression en deux temps
de la C VAE après une première baisse de
10 milliards d'euros des impôts de
production qui nous a permis de revenir
après de deux points d'écart avec
l'Allemagne là où il y en avait trois
auparavant
je sais que les doutes se sont exprimés
je continue à être profondément
convaincu de la nécessité d'une nouvelle
baisse des impôts de production de 4
milliards en 2023 et 4 milliards en 2024
je voudrais simplement rappeler des
faits simples à l'appui de cette
conviction quand vous regardez la
situation de l'économie française depuis
30 ans
elle se caractérise hélas par le niveau
d'impôt le plus élevé de tous les pays
la zone euro et le niveau
d'inscriredialisation le plus faible de
tous les pays de la zone euro et bien
c'est ce sur quoi je continuerai à me
battre c'est ce contre quoi nous nous
battrons avec toute la majorité
inlassablement la Vogue France n'a pas
vocation à voir une industrie faible et
des impôts élevés je préférerais qu'elle
ait des impôts plus faibles et une
industrie plus forte c'est le sens de
cette baisse des impôts de production
c'est le sens de cette baisse en deux
fois de la CVAE qui doit nous permettre
de continuer leur industrialisation du
pays il n'y aura pas de
réindustrialisation avec un écart
d'imposition aussi important par rapport
à nos grands partenaires européens
alors certains me disent qu'il est trop
tôt pour continuer la baisse des impôts
de production ce sont à mon avis les
mêmes qui me diront demain que c'est
trop tard on me dit que c'est un cadeau
qui est faite aux entreprises mais ce
sont les mêmes qui ensuite viennent
pleurer dans mon bureau en disant nos
industries ne sont pas suffisamment
compétitives on me dit qu'il faut
protéger les collectivités locales mais
ce sont les mêmes qui essayent d'attirer
sur leur commune à juste titre des
entreprises industrielles pourvoyeuses
d'emploi de richesse et de prospérité
pour leur territoire
certains me disent mais vous vous
trompez totalement de direction la bonne
direction c'est augmenter des impôts au
nom de la justice fiscale
je tiens à le rappeler que malgré les
efforts que nous avons menés avec
constance depuis six ans avec cette
majorité le président de la République
malgré la baisse de 10 milliards d'euros
sur les impôts de production
malgré la baisse des impôts sur les
sociétés qui étaient ramenées de 33,3 à
25 % malgré la baisse de l'impôt sur le
revenu malgré la suppression la taxe
d'habitation malgré la suppression la
redevance audiovisuelle malgré une
baisse générale de près de 50 milliards
d'euros d'impôts au cours des cinq
dernières années nous avons toujours le
taux de prélèvement obligatoire le plus
élevé des pays européens derrière le
Danemark
c'est donc vous dire qu'il nous reste
une marge de manœuvre pour baisser les
impôts dans notre pays et être
compétitif du point de vue fiscal je
voudrais dire également
à tout les sénateurs aujourd'hui à quel
point je suis le premier défenseur de la
justice fiscale mais je souhaite aller
chercher l'argent là où il se trouve
c'est à dire pas dans la poche des
Français mais chez les gens du numérique
qui doivent payer leurs taxes sur les
activités digitales qui nous rapportent
660 millions d'euros cette année la
France a été la première à mettre en
place cette mesure de justice fiscale
aller chercher l'argent où il se trouve
c'est mettre en place la taxation
minimale à l'impôt sur les sociétés pour
éviter toute optimisation fiscale si
nous n'y arrivons pas au niveau européen
d'ici la fin de l'année nous le mettrons
en place au niveau national au début de
l'année 2023 et aller chercher l'argent
là où il se trouve c'est évidemment
refuser les rangs des énergéticiens en
mettant en place ce prélèvement
obligatoire qui va nous rapporter
l'année prochaine va aussi milliards
d'euros je suis pour la justice fiscale
mais je ne suis pas pour qu'on augmente
les impôts des Français et je considère
que les deux sont parfaitement
compatibles la deuxième constante de ce
budget que rappellera le bénis sur les
comptes publics c'est la maîtrise de la
dépense publique
nous avons une loi de programmation des
finances publiques qui doit nous
permettre de revenir sous les 3% en 2027
et je viens ici dans cette assemblée de
la sagesse en comptant sur la grande
sagesse les sénatrices et des sénateurs
pour éviter les dérapages à 15 milliards
d'euros de dépenses supplémentaires que
nous avons connu à l'Assemblée nationale
car ces dérapages de 15 milliards
d'euros témoignent soit d'une
indifférence totale à la bonne tenue des
finances de la nation soit ce que je ne
peux croire une indifférence totale à la
vie de nos compatriotes car je rappelle
que ces 15 milliards d'euros ont été
gagés sur le bouclier électricité que
nous avons mis en place et 15 milliards
d'euros s'ils étaient financés par la
suppression d'une partie du bouclier
énergétique signifierait une
augmentation de 40% du prix de
l'électricité une hausse la facture de
près de 600 euros par an en moyenne sur
les ménages français
ni la différence à la bonne tenue des
finances de la nation ni l'indifférence
à la vie quotidienne de nos compatriotes
ne sont acceptables et ne correspondent
aux orientations notre majorité enfin la
troisième constante notre politique
budgétaire c'est notre engagement
européen de ce point de vue je compte
sur les sénatrices les sénateurs pour
que nous trouvions ensemble un accord
sur la loi de programmation des finances
publiques je pense qu'il est bon pour la
nation française d'avoir de la
visibilité sur le finance publique à 5
ans je pense qu'il est bon pour nos
partenaires européens de savoir que les
finances publiques de la France la
deuxième économie de la zone euro sont
bien tenues je pense qu'il est bon de
prendre des engagements en termes de
réforme de structure sur l'assurance
chômage ou sur les retraites je pense
qu'il est rassurant pour nos
compatriotes rassurants pour les
entrepreneurs de se dire mais voilà où
nous allons voilà quand on va commencer
la baisse la dette publique voilà quand
nous retrouverons les 3% déficits
publics et la seule garantie législative
que nous ayons de donner de la
visibilité à nos compatriotes sur les
finances publiques c'est la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
votre proposition consiste à aligner la
baisse des dépenses publiques de l'État
sur celle des collectivités locales
moins 0,5 en volume je pense que c'est
une proposition qui est juste et qui
s'entend et qui est honnête vous avez
proposé pour cela 37 milliards d'euros
de réduction des dépenses nous allons
dire que c'est ambitieux très ambitieux
mais je suis certain en tout cas que
notre travail en commun doit nous
permettre de faire émerger les
propositions réalistes et concrètes et
je l'espère de trouver un compromis sur
cette loi de programmation des finances
publiques dont je persiste à penser
qu'elle est rassurante pour nos
compatriotes rassurantes pour nos
partenaires européens et responsable du
strict de point de vue de la bonne tenue
de nos finances publiques je vous
remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à présent monsieur Gabriel Attal
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général monsieur
le ministre cher Bruno Le Maire Mesdames
Messieurs les Sénateurs
nous sommes réunis pour examiner le
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques qui le 25 octobre
dernier a été rejeté par l'Assemblée
nationale ce jour là j'ai pris acte du
choix souverain des députés mais je n'ai
pu m'empêcher d'exprimer une conviction
que je veux partager avec vous
aujourd'hui nous pouvons avoir des
désaccords il est d'ailleurs normal sans
que les groupes politiques n'est pas la
même analyse de ce qu'il convient de
faire pour les 5 prochaines années oui
nous pouvons avoir des désaccords sur
l'évolution des dépenses ou sur la
manière dont les collectivités
territoriales contribuent à l'effort de
maîtrise j'ai bien vu qu'un certain
nombre d'amendements avaient été adoptés
sur ce point en commission des finances
pour autant il me semble que laisser
notre pays sans cadre et sans
trajectoire et corneret profondément sa
crédibilité notamment vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires européens
ce n'est ni une menace ni en épouvantail
c'est simplement le rappel d'un principe
de réalité principe de réalité et même
principe de bon sens qui peut croire que
notre pays se porterait mieux parce que
nous aurions décidé d'avancer sans
balises ou sans points de repère qui
peut croire que le rejet du sérieux
budgétaire est une réponse au problème
que nous devons résoudre qui peut croire
que notre pays serait plus fort ou plus
libre parce qu'il aurait renoncé à la
maîtrise de ses finances publiques à
plus forte raison dans le contexte que
nous connaissons marqués à la fois par
la hausse des prix et par la hausse des
taux
la réalité la responsabilité le bon sens
votre assemblée on a à nouveau fait
preuve en adoptant jeudi dernier en
commission des finances un une loi de
programmation des finances publiques sur
laquelle nous sommes saisis aujourd'hui
je vois qu'une question préalable a été
déposée par le groupe CRCE je formule le
souhait qu'elle ne soit pas adoptée
puisque je le dis nous avons besoin de
ce cadre pour les années à venir c'est
un enjeu de crédibilité pour notre pays
et contrairement à ce que j'ai pu
entendre ce projet de loi de
programmation n'est pas un carcan mais
un cadre c'est un cadre qui rappelle les
objectifs que nous avons fixés les
engagements que nous avons pris durant
les Français devant la campagne
présidentielle ces engagements sont
clairs ramener le déficit public sous la
barre des 3% d'ici la fin du quinquennat
et stabiliser notre endettement en
public à partir de 2026
cette trajectoire est crédible elle est
d'autant plus crédible qu'elle est déjà
engagée le déficit était je le rappelle
de 9% en 2020 nous l'avons descendu à
6,5% en 2021 il sera cette année de 4,9%
0,1 point de mieux que la berbe
prévision réalisée en juillet dernier
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir demain
puisque je serai auditionné par votre
commission des finances sur le deuxième
projet de loi de finances rectificative
pour 2022 cette trajectoire est déjà
engagée et cette trajectoire ne peut
être différée en tant que ministre des
comptes publics j'ai le devoir de
rappeler que l'effort de maîtrise de nos
comptes ne peut pas être remis à plus
tard quand un pays comptabilise plus de
3000 milliards d'euros de dettes plus
tard c'est trop tard
quand les taux d'intérêt remontent plus
tard c'est trop tard quand la charge de
la dette augmente elle sera de 51
milliards d'euros l'année prochaine plus
tard c'est trop tard alors oui nous
devons poursuivre les forts de maîtrise
des dépenses publiques il ne s'agit pas
de mettre en œuvre un plan programme
d'austérité mais simplement d'éviter le
dérapage et de se fixer un cadre
d'évolution de la dépense j'ai bien
conscience que la majorité sénatoriale
souhaite que nous allions plus loin en
ce qui concerne la maîtrise des dépenses
de l'État à cet égard des amendements
ont été présentés adoptés en commission
des finances sur les articles 2 3 et 4
pour que les forfaits par les
administrations centrales sur les
dépenses soit alignées à celui proposé
pour les collectivités locales
c'est-à-dire une baisse annuelle de 0,5%
en volume Bruno Le Maire l'a dit il y a
un instant nous sommes ouverts
effectivement à ce que il y ait parité
dans l'effort puisqu'il était prévu un
effort de 0,4% pour l'état de 0,5 pour
les collectivités locales vous avez
également proposé adopter un amendement
qui exclut une grande partie des
dépenses de l'État prise en compte pour
la maîtrise des dépenses publiques il
s'agit d'un agrégat qui exclut la charge
de la dette ainsi que toutes les mesures
de soutien notamment économiques et
sanitaire bien entendu nous sommes ici
pour discuter de la trajectoire c'est
même l'objet de ce débat et je veux
simplement préciser et Bruno Le Maire
l'a rappelé il y a un instant que cela
représenterait une baisse des dépenses
supplémentaires par rapport aux
économies déjà prévues de l'ordre de 37
milliards d'euros à horizon 2027 par
rapport à la trajectoire que nous avons
présenté ce qui ramènerait le solde de
fin de quinquennat de 2,9 selon la
trajectoire que nous proposons à 1,7%.
nous aurons ce débat dans un instant et
tout au long de la soirée mais
permettez-moi juste de dire qu'un tel
ajustement
doit pouvoir être atteint de manière
crédible 37 milliards d'euros à trouver
d'ici à 2027 25 milliards d'euros à
trouver d'ici à 2025 il y a un article
dans cette loi de programmation je crois
que c'est l'article 12 qui prévoit
l'évolution des dépenses pour les
grandes missions budgétaires de l'État
dans les trois années à venir par
cohérence si votre assemblée décidait de
baisser ou un effort supplémentaire
d'économie de 25 milliards d'euros à
horizon 2025 cet article devra également
être amendé pour dire où c'est où ces 25
milliards d'euros seraient pris ce qui
serait pris sur la défense de
l'éducation nationale
sur la transition écologique nous
pouvons avoir ce débat mais 25 milliards
d'euros à trouver en plus ici à 2025
c'est une somme d'économie importante
mais Bruno Le Maire l'a dit nous sommes
toujours ouverts à faire davantage
d'économies à montrer que nous faisons
davantage d'efforts s'agissant de l'État
et nous aurons le débat le gouvernement
a déposé je l'ai défendrai des articles
des amendements pour rétablir les
articles 2 3 et 4 dans leur version
originelle puisque nous pensons que la
trajectoire qui figure dans cette loi de
programmation des finances publiques
permet une maîtrise de la progression
des dépenses mais le fait dans un cadre
soutenable
une politique austéritaire trop brutale
qui sabrerait dans les services publics
dans les toutes prochaines années
auraient un impact très difficile dans
la vie quotidienne des Français est
probablement dans la conduite de la
nation et donc dans l'activité
économique au cours de ce débat nous
ferons preuve d'ouverture sur le
rehaussement donc de la trajectoire que
nous proposons elle n'a rien
d'intangible et Bruno Le Maire l'a dit
nous chercherons toujours à trouver un
compromis dans les différentes étapes de
l'examen de ce texte mais nous ne
pouvons pas adhérer un objectif qui nous
semble totalement inatteignable sauf à
faire des choix qui seraient
dommageables pour nos services publics
qui reviendraient à pratiquer une forme
d'austérité je le disais il y a une
minute nous proposons le sérieux nous
voulons ni de la gabegie ni de
l'austérité j'en reviens donc à la
conviction que je veux partager avec
vous aujourd'hui ce projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques est
un élément central de notre crédibilité
[Musique]
tout simplement vous dire c'est que la
discussion qui démarre aujourd'hui doit
nous permettre de doter la France d'une
boîte de programmation c'est notre
responsabilité et c'est notre devoir car
la situation inverse aurait pour seul
effet d'affaiblir le pays la deuxième
condition que je veux partager avec vous
c'est que cette trajectoire des finances
publiques est aussi un contrat que le
gouvernement passe avec le Parlement et
donc avec les Français qui sont
représentés ce texte cela doit être doit
être un texte pour le Parlement pour
partager un cap pour mieux piloter les
finances publiques pour s'assurer que
les lois de finances annuelles
s'inscrivent en cohérence avec la
trajectoire que le gouvernement propose
je veux rappeler d'ailleurs que la
nouvelle version de la Golf
issue de la révision dite verte
Saint-Martin donc d'une initiative
parlementaire à renforcer la portée de
la loi de programmation pluriannuelle
une traduction concrète en est que le
gouvernement doit désormais justifier
devant le Haut conseil aux finances
publiques les éventuels écarts par
rapport à la trajectoire pluriannuelle
de la loi de programmation des finances
publiques en amont du dépôt du projet de
loi de finance de l'année donc pour dire
les choses simplement il me semblerait
un peu baroque que le Parlement après
avoir a juste titre
œuvrer pour renforcer son pouvoir de
contrôle ce prive d'un important
instrument de ce contrôle
et je dis une chose simple si l'on veut
passer du quoi qu'il en coûte combien ça
coûte comme nous souhaitons tous il faut
renforcer la capacité du Parlement
évaluer les dispositifs je sais que vous
partagez ce constat et les travaux que
vous avez conduits en commission des
finances en témoignent ce texte prévoit
c'est son article 7 le bornage à 4 ans
des dépenses fiscales j'ai noté
l'adoption en commission des finances
d'un amendement proposé par le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
qui proposent de ramener ce bornage à
trois ans ce texte prévoit et c'est son
article 15 que les créations extensions
ou prolongations d'un dispositif d'aide
aux entreprises instaurées après le 1er
janvier 2023 ne sont applicables que
pour une durée précise par le texte qui
les institut dans la limite de 5 ans cet
article prévoit aussi la remise
systématique d'une évaluation là encore
il renforce le rôle du Parlement dans sa
capacité à contrôler le pilotage des
finances publiques par l'État
ce texte prévoit c'est son article 21
des évaluations de la qualité de la
dépense publique dans les conclusions
seront transmises au Parlement au plus
tard le 1er avril de chaque année à cet
égard un amendement adopté à
l'initiative du rapporteur général
propose d'introduire un certain nombre
de précisions pour renforcer
l'information et donc la capacité de
contrôle du Parlement je le disais nous
ne pouvons différer les ports de
l'effort de maîtrise de nos finances
publiques y parvenir suppose de partager
un même sentiment de responsabilité
responsabilité vis-à-vis de notre pays
de sa crédibilité de sa capacité
d'action de son indépendance aussi y
parvenir suppose aussi de répartir
l'effort entre l'ensemble des
administrations publiques l'État et ses
opérateurs la sécurité sociale et les
collectivités locales
l'article 23 qui précise les modalités
de respect de l'eau Dedel fixé l'article
16 a fait l'objet d'un amendement de
suppression lors de l'examen du texte en
commission des finances cet amendement
de suppression n'a d'ailleurs pas été
porté uniquement par le rapporteur
général mais par un certain nombre de
groupes d'oppositions j'en prends acte
tout en rappelant que ce mécanisme
constitue à mes yeux une solution
d'équilibre pour faire en sorte que les
collectivités territoriales contribuent
de façon juste équitable et équilibrée à
l'effort collectif
vous le savez les associations d'élus
nous ont toutes fait savoir qu'elles ne
souhaitaient pas la reconduction à
l'identique des contrats de Cahors cette
forme de contractualisation avait
succédé en 2017 au baisse massive de DGF
et était vécu par beaucoup comme une
mise sous tutelle nous avons donc
abandonné tourner la page des contrats
de Cahors il y a l'issue d'une très
longue concertation avec les
associations d'élus que nous avons
menées avec mes collègues Christophe
Béchu et Caroline cailleux nous avons
proposé les pactes de confiance à ceux
qui pensent qu'il ne s'agit que d'un
glissement sémantique je leur dis
regardez les déclarations des
associations d'élus je ne dis pas ici
évidemment que toutes les associations
d'élus ont applaudit dès demain la mise
en place ou la proposition des pactes de
confiance mais un certain nombre
d'associations d'élus ont eu des propos
en soutien à la logique qui sous-tende
les pacte de confiance je peux citer les
représentants des intercommunalités de
France qui ont clairement exprimé que
les packs de confiance tournaient la
page des contrats de Cahors je peux
citer l'Association des départements de
France et je cite ici à communiquer du
président Sauvet nous sommes prêts à une
participation de tous les départements à
la trajectoire en volume et non en
valeur avec une réduction de nos
dépenses de 0,5% par rapport au niveau
d'inflation je pense que la solution à
laquelle nous sommes parvenus est un
effort supportable et tenable dès lors
que le gouvernement ne nous met pas de
dépenses supplémentaires sur le dos pour
être totalement complet il disait même
qu'il validait ce dispositif des PACS de
confiance dès lors que l'État
s'engageait à sortir des dépenses prises
en compte les fameuses ais qui sont des
dépenses évidemment non pilotables pour
les départements et je me suis engagé à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que les is
ne figurent pas dans les dépenses prises
en compte pour le mécanisme de l'article
une large majorité dans cette émission
considère qu'il faut abandonner tous
mécanisme de
prise en compte des dérapages pour
corriger une trajectoire de dérapage
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
l'article 23 a été supprimé en
commission là-dessus je vais vous dire
notre conviction
ce dispositif quand bien même il serait
adopté par le Parlement ne serait
probablement pas activé parce que j'ai
vu des associations d'élus des
collectivités locales parfaitement
conscientes et lucides de la situation
budgétaire de notre pays parfaitement
consciente et lucide de leur capacité à
maîtriser aussi leurs dépenses mais
avoir un cadre qui permet de garantir
que lorsque si un dérapage venait à
arriver alors nous regardions pour les
500 plus grandes collectivités de notre
pays on parle des 500 plus grandes
collectivités de notre pays celles qui
ont contribué à faire des rappeler la
trajectoire pour voir avec elle comment
revenir vers une trajectoire plus
soutenable c'est une mesure de
crédibilité aussi pour la trajectoire
que nous fixons vis-à-vis de celles et
ceux qui nous regardent
je ne partage pas donc l'idée selon
laquelle la suppression de cet article
23 serait justifiée sa vocation n'est
pas de punir ou d'infantibiliser ou
d'infantiliser l'objectif c'est de nous
donner un cadre et un objectif de
maîtrise des dépenses de fonctionnement
pas pour entraver les collectivités mais
au contraire pour les aider à dégager de
la capacité d'autofinancement pour
investir oui nous pensons toujours que
le mécanisme proposé à l'article 23 est
juste et pertinent c'est la raison pour
laquelle le gouvernement a déposé un
amendement pour qu'il soit rétabli nous
aurons donc l'occasion d'en discuter de
façon beaucoup plus approfondie voilà
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs les
quelques réflexions que je voulais
partager avec vous avant d'entamer
l'examen de ce projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques en
somme nous pouvons avoir des divergences
sur les paramètres sur les points de
passage ou sur la manière dont chaque
catégorie d'administration publique doit
contribuer à l'effort collectif
mais nous devrions tous nous retrouver
autour du fait que la sixième puissance
mondiale ne peut pas se dérober à ses
obligations de sérieux budgétaires et en
juger les échanges que nous avons d'ores
et déjà eu les travaux que vous avez eus
en commission des finances je crois que
nous nous retrouverons autour de cet
objectif je vous remercie merci Monsieur
le Ministre la parole est à présent à
notre rapporteur de la commission des
finances Jean-François Husson vous avez
10 minutes chers collègues
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des finances mes chers
collègues
nous y voilà nous examinons aujourd'hui
le projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques pour les années 2023
à 2027 un exercice important principe
puisqu'il est appelé à définir la
trajectoire des finances publiques qui
guidera ensuite les lois de finances
pour les 5 prochaines années en outre ce
texte concrétise nos engagements
européens au niveau national
toutefois son examen au Sénat intervient
dans un contexte un peu différent à vous
le cette année d'une part les
gouvernements du précédent quinquennat
n'ont pas jugé utiles de modifier la loi
de programmation
2018-2022 laissant ainsi en place une
trajectoire totalement décorée des
événements traversés par notre pays et
au répercussions pourtant majeures sur
la trajectoire de nos finances publiques
qu'il s'agisse par exemple du mouvement
des gilets jaunes ou ensuite de la crise
sanitaire économique
cela a à mon sens quelque peu et cornée
la portée de ce texte depuis 2018
d'autre part et surtout le Sénat est
appelé à se prononcer sur le texte
déposé par le Gouvernement dans la
mesure où le projet de loi a été rejeté
en première lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale saisie en premier lieu
ce contexte est en posé que penser de
ses plats de programmation
s'agissant d'abord du scénario
macroéconomique du gouvernement il est
clair que celui-ci repose sur des
hypothèses très si ce n'est trop
favorable les prévisions de croissance
effective au potentielles sont en effet
très éloignés du consensus des
économistes
s'agissant de l'hypothèse de réduction
du taux de chômage à 5% en 2027 je pense
messieurs les ministres qu'il serait bon
que le gouvernement ne confondent pas le
slogan de campagne avec la rigueur de la
prévision d'un scénario macroéconomique
même si je souhaite à notre pays
d'atteindre ce résultat
cette situation s'explique notamment sur
le fait que le gouvernement surestime
dans son projet de programmation les
effets à court terme de quelques
réformes structurelles qu'ils souhaitent
pour tente engager
j'en viens maintenant à la trajectoire
des finances publiques qui nous est
proposée par le gouvernement
une trajectoire qui n'est pas assez
ambitieuse en prévoyante en effet une
réduction du déficit à 3% du PIB mais
seulement à partir de 2027 en effet nos
partenaires européens devraient
retrouver ce niveau dès 2025
l'endettement public ne refleurait quant
à lui pas avant 2026 et resterait à des
niveaux encore très importants près de
111% du PIB en 2027 le rythme de
redressement de nos comptes publics est
insuffisant il est beaucoup trop lent
cette trajectoire je le disais n'est pas
ambitieuse mais elle est aussi en trompe
l'oeil le gouvernement revendique de
diminuer la dépense publique en volume
entre 2023 et 2027 toutefois il ne
retraite ni les mesures liées au crises
sanitaires économiques énergétique ni la
charge de la dette et en retenant pour
périmètre les seuls dépenses ordinaires
les dépenses publiques enregistrent en
réalité une progression de
0,6% en volume
en outre le gouvernement impose aux
administrations locales et sociales de
réaliser un effort d'économie compris
entre 25 et 27 milliards d'euros alors
que dans le même temps les
administrations centrales n'en réalisent
pas
d'ailleurs la trajectoire de hausse des
crédits des missions budgétaires de
l'État inscrite dans le projet de loi
montre que si le gouvernement a choisi
les politiques sur lesquelles il
souhaite ajouter des crédits il a par
contre renoncer à identifier celle sur
lesquelles des économies pourraient être
réalisés et bien compte tenu des élèves
de ces éléments la commission des
finances considère en l'état que la
trajectoire du gouvernement n'est pas
acceptable d'une part parce qu'elle
manque d'ambition en termes de
redressement des comptes et de maîtrise
de la dépense et d'autre part parce
qu'on demande moins d'efforts à l'état
qu'aux administrations publiques la
commission des Finances n'a pour autant
pas choisi de rejeter ce projet de loi
et là pour répondre aux deux principaux
écueils identifiés adoptés une nouvelle
trajectoire de baisers
plus sérieuse et plus ambitieuse pour
retrouver le chemin de l'équilibre ainsi
le texte issu de nos travaux prévoit que
les dépenses je le redis hors mesure de
crise et hors charges de la dette des
administrations centrales devront ainsi
diminuer de 0,5% en volume chaque année
dès 2023 ce qui correspond exactement à
ce que le gouvernement demande aux
collectivités territoriales laissant
d'ailleurs le soin à ses collectivités
de trouver les voies et moyens pour y
arriver cette nouvelle trajectoire
permettrait ainsi de ramener le déficit
public en dessous de 3% et dès 2025 ce
qui nous paraît être un objectif
ambitieux certes mais aussi réaliste
cette proposition d'abord est d'ailleurs
répond à quatre objectifs premièrement
faire refuer le déficit et l'endettement
public plus rapidement que ne le prévoit
le gouvernement deuxièmement et c'est
important assurer la pleine contribution
des administrations centrales
troisièmement préserver nos dépenses
sociales et régaliennes et enfin
quatrièmement conserver des marges
d'intervention face à la crise cette
trajectoire impliquerait de réaliser des
efforts dès 2023 à hauteur de presque 4
milliards d'euros en l'état actuel du
projet de loi de finance au cours des
années 2023 2027 nous devrons donc
trouver de nouvelles sources d'économies
en mettant en oeuvre des réformes
structurelles baisse à long terme des
effectifs engagement d'une réforme des
retraites ambitieuses réorganisation
pourquoi pas de certains services
publics comme l'audiovisuel éventuel
décalage dans le temps de certaines
trajectoires programmatiques d'évolution
des crédits de certaines politiques
publiques non
réforme des prestations sociales nous
avons du travail et des possibilités
notre commission des finances a
d'ailleurs rendu 109 rapports depuis
2015 riche à eux seuls de mesure qui
nourriront nos réflexions cette
trajectoire repose également sur un
paralylisme des exigences pesant sur
l'état et les collectivités
territoriales offrant ainsi un juste
même si il est difficile équilibre dans
la répartition de l'effort réalisé pour
maîtriser la dépense publique entre les
administrations
cela nous paraît de bon sens mais je le
dis cela nous paraît aussi juste nous ne
proposons pas de revenir sur la
trajectoire des administration de
sécurité sociale qui apparaît d'ailleurs
déjà relativement ambitieuse au regard
des défis qui les attendent pour les
prochaines années
s'agissant des collectivités
territoriales ici au Sénat les efforts
qui leur sont demandés dans le projet de
votre programmation tel que déposé par
le Gouvernement sont conséquents il faut
il ne faut pas le nier en prévoyant
notamment une trajectoire des concours
financiers de l'État dont la croissance
en valeur masque en fait et en réalité
une contraction de 4 milliards d'euros
en volume
parallèlement est également prévu un
objectif d'évolution de la dépense
locale le fameux oddle correspondant lui
à une diminution des dépenses de
fonctionnement de 0,5% en volume soit un
effort plus rigoureux encore que sous
les précédentes loi de programmation
déjà par le passé leur contribution au
redressement des finances publiques a
été déterminante je veux rappeler ainsi
à cet instant qu'entre 2013 et 2016 les
collectivités locales ont porté les deux
tiers de la réduction du déficit public
alors même qu'elle représentait moins de
20% de la dépense publique
de même elles ont su réalisé 11
milliards d'euros d'économies sur leurs
dépenses de fonctionnement entre 2019 et
2021 alors même que les contrats de
Cahors n'ont pas été appliqués en 2020
et 2021
les collectivités locales ont donc
démontré leur esprit de responsabilité
face à la nécessité et à l'urgence de
redresser pour les rétablir nos comptes
publics
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
commission a supprimé le système de
surveillance et de sanction des
collectivités proposées par l'article 23
je vois à Monsieur le Ministre des
comptes publics que nous n'avons pas
tout à fait la même lecture et en tous
les cas pas la même vision des
conséquences d'un encadrement soft et
d'ailleurs vous avez rappelé à l'instant
que ça n'était pas forcément nécessaire
et bien effectivement si c'est pas
nécessaire car rien à craindre vous
verrez on va s'en occuper dans le débat
qui arrive tout à l'heure il paraît en
effet tellement ta robots des engagement
du gouvernement à mettre en place une
nouvelle méthode fondée sur la confiance
dans le respect du principe de la libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales
enfin la commission des finances a
enrichi le texte en adotant plusieurs
amendements qui s'inscrivent dans un
objectif de maîtrise plus rigoureuse de
la dépense
où sont guidés par un souci de vigilance
quant à la mise en œuvre effective des
mesures figurant dans ce texte en
conclusion c'est ce texte tel qu'ici du
travaux de la commission des finances et
compléter des éventuels amendements que
nous pourrions retenir au cours des
prochaines heures que je vous propose
d'adopter je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est à présent à notre collègue et Madame
Elisabeth Doisneau rapporteur pour ravi
de la commission des affaires sociales
vous avez 5 minutes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres Messieurs les Présidents et
rapporteurs générales de la commission
des finances chers collègues la
commission des affaires sociales a
exprimer un réel scepticisme face à la
trajectoire financière des régimes
obligatoires de base de sécurité sociale
du fond de solidarité vieillesse et de
l'objectif national de dépenses
d'assurance maladie contenue dans ce
projet de loi elle a d'ailleurs
réitéressée doutes ce matin même dans le
cadre de l'examen du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
s'agissant de London allons au fait
monsieur le ministre qui devrait frôler
la barre des 250 milliards d'euros dès
2024 soit plus de 5 fois le budget de la
défense ou plus de 5 de 4 fois celui
d'éducation nationale ça me permet de
aussi de
conceptualiser si je puis dire les
sommes en question la trajectoire
affichée bien que dynamique semble le
moins ambitieuse et même pour tout dire
difficilement tenable
difficilement tenable pourquoi parce que
les incertitudes sont grandes sur
l'impact financier de la crise sanitaire
en 2023 et dans les années
ultérieures
difficilement tenable car nous voyons
bien l'ampleur des besoins de santé
l'ampleur des attentes en matière de
rénovation de l'hôpital mais aussi
l'ampleur de l'impact financier que
représente aujourd'hui le choc
d'innovation dans le secteur du
médicament
difficilement tenable car le contexte
inflationniste rend le taux réel de
progression bien moindre que celui
affiché et sur ce point si le ministre
des contes publics considère que
l'inflation ne se reproduit pas de
manière
identique sur les dépenses de santé
force est de constater qu'elle est
parfois plus forte encore sur certaines
décharges principales des hôpitaux comme
l'énergie
difficilement tenable enfin et surtout
car le gouvernement comme le directeur
de la CNAM reconnaisse qu'il faudra
prendre des mesures fortes d'économie
pour garantir le respect de cette
trajectoire
or quel serait ces mesures nous n'avons
obtenu aucune information sur ce point
régulera-t-on enfin l'ONDAM de ville et
si oui comment ou bien cela signifie le
retour explicite d'économie sur
l'hôpital
quant au reste des robes je ne peux là
aussi que regretter le caractère
particulièrement lacunaire des
informations transmises par le
gouvernement pour maintenir à l'exemple
le plus significatif l'évolution des
dépenses de la branche vieillesse est
censée intégrer dès 2023 les effets
d'une réforme des retraites mais nous ne
connaissons ni les paramètres ni même
son impact financier ils ne sont pas
précisés dans un quelconque document et
malgré mes demandes réitérées je n'ai
pas eu de précision
néanmoins du fait du rôle d'une noix de
programmation c'est à dire en premier
lieu permettre au Parlement de vérifier
chaque année si la trajectoire fixée est
respectée ou non la commission des
affaires sociales a émis un avis
favorable à l'adoption des articles dont
elle était saisie sous relève sous
réserve de l'adoption de 5 amendements
que la commission des finances et je le
remercie à intégrer dans le texte
qu'elle a établi
outre un amendement de précision à
l'article 18 relatif aux charges de
gestion des organismes de sécurité
sociale ces amendements ont pour objet
de rendre tout effort sur l'ONDAM plus
équitable entre les différents acteurs
du monde de la santé et d'améliorer
également l'information du Parlement sur
les finances sociales ainsi à l'article
17 nous avons prolongé la trajectoire
des dépenses des robes et de l'ONDAM
jusqu'en 2026 et 2027
j'attire votre attention messieurs les
ministres sur le fait que le compteur
des écarts entre les dépenses prévues
par le projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale et celle figurant
dans la loi de programmation des
finances publiques doit concerner toutes
les lois de financement de sécurité
sociale jusqu'à l'année 2027 donc si
vous nous dites qu'il y aura une autre
loi de programmation avant 2026 je vous
invite à compléter le dispositif du
Sénat en ajoutant vous-même l'objectif
de et du FSV pour 2027 dans le même
esprit à l'article 24 nous avons
souhaité qu'une décomposition des
recettes des dépenses et du solde des
administrations de sécurité sociale
relatives à l'exercice clos soit adressé
au Parlement au moment du dépôt du
projet de loi d'approbation des comptes
de la Sécurité sociale enfin messieurs
les ministres à l'initiative de la
Commission des affaires sociales le
texte de nos collègues des finances
précisent que la mise en réserve de
l'ONDAM devra concerner de manière égale
tous les sous-objectifs en d'autres
termes il nous faudra cesser de faire
porter les gels de crédit principalement
à l'hôpital j'espère que nos débats en
séance publique nous permettront de
confirmer ces avancées je vous remercie
merci chers collègues et enfin la parole
est à Claude Raynal président de la
commission des finances Président vous
avez 5 minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres monsieur leur papa général
madame la rapporteur général mes chers
collègues les lois de programmation des
finances publiques n'ont pas dans notre
ordre juridique de caractère
contraignant elles sont néanmoins les
marqueurs des débuts de quinquennat en
ce qu'elles exposent les grandes
orientations de notre pays en matière de
finance publique qu'il s'agisse de sa
politique fiscale ou de ses priorités
budgétaires elles sont également
importantes vous l'avez dit à l'égard de
nos partenaires de la zone euro la
précédente loi de programmation
2018-2022 avait de grandes ambitions
réduire l'endettement public de plus de
5 points de PIB et ramener nos finances
publiques pratiquement à l'équilibre
entre temps de nombreux événements sont
survenus qu'il s'agissent du mouvement
des gilets jaunes du covid est désormais
de la crise énergétique et des tensions
internationales
chacun sait que ces objectifs n'ont pas
été atteints aucune révision de la
programmation n'a cependant été réalisé
comme le réclamait pourtant le Sénat dès
septembre 2019 nous pouvons nous
féliciter que le Gouvernement présente
enfin une nouvelle loi de programmation
même si celle-ci ne débute pas sous des
meilleurs hospices son cadrage
macroéconomique qui font sa crédibilité
est entouré de nombreuses certitudes
rappelées par le rapporteur général mais
rappeler également par vous monsieur les
ministres le gouvernement apparaît
optimiste au regard du consensus des
économistes en prévoyant une croyance
moyenne du PIB de 1,6% sur la période et
la teinte plein emploi même si j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire qu'il était dans
votre rôle monsieur le ministre de
retenir une perspective la moins
défavorable possible pour notre pays
sans vous écarter de trop cependant du
consensus ce qui me préoccupe davantage
ce sont les perspectives qui sont
dressées pour nos finances publiques je
constate que le gouvernement entend sur
la période quinquennale réduire les
prélèvements obligatoires de plusieurs
milliards d'euros principalement sur les
deux premières années de programmation
2023 et 2024 poursuivant ainsi sa
stratégie qualifiée de désarmement
fiscales de notre pays après la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation dans
les conséquences n'ont pas été
suffisamment anticipées de toute
évidence le gouvernement s'emploie finir
doté aux collectivités locales les
recettes fiscales dont elles disposent
avec une suppression sur deux ans de la
CVAE sans proposer de mécanismes
crédible de compensation pour ce qui
relève des comptes de l'État le
gouverneur de la Banque de France comme
le premier président de la Cour des
comptes l'ont pourtant dit à multiples
reprises nous n'avons pas les moyens de
procéder à de nouvelles baisse d'impôts
surtout si celle-ci ne sont pas gagées
je note d'ailleurs que on regarde
toujours sur les comparaisons
internationales des entreprises des
sujets par silo en silo on regarde
l'impôt sur les sociétés on compare on
regarde les impôts de production qu'on
compare mais par contre sur les niches
fiscales en faveur des entreprises c'est
curieux on fait assez peu de comparaison
internationales notamment par exemple
sur l'avantage du crédit un projet ce
qui est la lieu partout dans les mêmes
donc il faut tout regarder quand on fait
une comparaison internationale il faut
la regarder dans son ensemble et donc
cette stratégie conduit inévitablement à
contraindre toujours plus dépenses
publiques même si la trajectoire est vue
par certains comme peu ambitieuse nul
doute que la faiblesse entretenue et
volontaire de nos recettes publiques
conduira à de nouvelles coupes
budgétaires sur des politiques publiques
pourtant prioritaire et amener à bien
des réformes dites structurelles visant
un manquablement notre modèle social
qu'il s'agisse de réduire
l'indemnisation des demandeurs d'emploi
ou de rehausser l'âge de départ en
retraite le risque est réel également de
contraindre l'investissement public
local alors même que celui-ci est
indispensable pour notre transition
énergétique et la modernisation de nos
infrastructures par ailleurs je ne peux
que déplorer comme la majorité de mes
collègues la manière d'envisager les
relations entre l'État et les
collectivités locales et Monsieur le
Ministre des comptes publics nous avons
pas tout à fait convaincu dans votre
vision de l'article 23 car sous la force
d'or retour de nouveaux contrats de
Cahors doté de mécanismes de correction
individuelle et d'une possibilité
d'exclusion de certaines dotations de
l'État
fort heureusement notre assemblée je le
crois s'apprête à supprimer ce funeste
article 23 en conclusion si une loi de
programmation est nécessaire je partage
cette idée en ce qu'elle fixe une
trajectoire plus réelle pour nos
finances publiques cette trajectoire
donc doit être revue et nos départs
devraient permettre à chacun d'exprimer
ses priorités je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Pascal ça vole des lits les membres du
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste ont déposé une motion
distribuée sous le numéro 60endant à
opposer la question préalable au texte
en discussion la parole est aussi nature
ça vole des lits pour nous présenter la
motion vous avez 10 minutes monsieur le
sénateur
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la Commission monsieur le
rapporteur général messieurs les
ministres et mes chers collègues nous
aurions pu avoir ce débat déjà il y a
quelques mois
contact avant que vous transmettiez à
Bruxelles le programme de stabilité de
la France puisque la copie est
exactement la même
la loi de programmation est validée par
des instances non élues avant les
représentants du peuple rassemblés au
Parlement et il y a meilleure façon nous
semble-t-il d'associer la nation la
trajectoire des finances publiques que
nous avons à discuter comme à chaque
occasion de Paris circonstances les
travailleurs et les travailleurs ont le
droit à un affront supplémentaire il
faudrait faire la réforme des retraites
et celle de l'assurance chômage car je
cite la comparaison inopportune du
président de la République sur France 2
je le cite
47,1% de prélèvements obligatoires on
est au-dessus de tous les voisins
européens et ça nous a été répété par le
ministre le maire par contre le
président dit aussi par contre il y a
une chose sur laquelle on est en dessous
de tous les voisins c'est ça et là le
vlog qui nous brandit carte
une carte du nombre d'heures travaillées
tout au long d'une vie
et bah écoutez monsieur le Président de
la République messieurs les ministres il
y a d'autres cartes
15,1% de l'emploi salarié est temporaire
selon les chiffres de l'OCDE 10 points
de plus que le Royaume-Uni 5 points de
plus que la Grèce 3,5 7 points de plus
que l'Allemagne
13,8% de l'emploi total est à temps
partiel c'est plus que la Bulgarie la
Roumanie la Hongrie la Lituanie la
Croatie le Portugal la Pologne et j'en
passe avec 80,8% des 25 64 ans en âge de
travailler sont au travail
la France est deux points au dessus de
la moyenne européenne des pays de l'OCDE
et de ceux de l'Union européenne et même
selon les heures travaillées par
travailleur la France est devant
l'Allemagne devant le Danemark devant le
Luxembourg devant les Pays-Bas la
Norvège l'Islande l'Autriche et la Suède
enfin un travailleur en France produit
67 dollars par heure travaillé soit 20%
de plus que la moyenne européenne
donc ils sont massivement en emploi trop
souvent dans des conditions précaires et
demeure davantage productifs que nos
voisins européens telle est la vérité
économique et sociale qui devrait servir
de base à la programmation des dépenses
publiques de notre pays la case sociale
entreprise par la réforme de l'assurance
chômage est fondée sur des hypothèses
irréalistes qui sous-tend ce projet de
loi de programmation et là je cite le
Haut Conseil des finances publiques le
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques pour les années 2023
2027 repose sur un scénario
macroéconomique quasiment identique à
celui du programme de stabilité de 2022
2027 alors même que le Haut Conseil
avait estimé nécessaire dans son avis du
26 juillet 2022 dans corriger plusieurs
éléments le Haut Conseil avait notamment
appelé à revoir les hypothèses d'écart
de production et de croissance
potentielle sur des bases plus prudentes
fin de citation
alors il faut comprendre ce qui est des
cartes de production pour percevoir
derrière ces indicateurs de ce que veut
dire le Haut Conseil l'écart de
production est un indicateur économique
qui mesure la différence entre la
production réelle d'une économie et sa
production potentielle c'est-à-dire le
volume maximal de bien et de services
qu'elle peut produire quand elle
fonctionne à plein régime en utilisant
toutes ses capacités messieurs les
ministres je vous ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'attention et je vous le dis
avec beaucoup de respect vous n'avez pas
le monopole de la responsabilité
pour faire une phrase qui parle à
certains qui étaient sur le monopole du
cœur à l'époque le Haut Conseil a l'air
que la croissance française est déjà à
son niveau maximal que les réformes
districtuelles de l'assurance chômage et
des retraites notamment ni changeront
rien ou pas grand chose la raison elle
est simple je me répète en France en
France les gens travaillent déjà
beaucoup et les emplois les mieux
rémunérés et les plus attractifs sont
déjà pourvus et tout le monde le sait
ici tout le monde le sait basé sur une
combinaison d'hypothèses optimiste le
gouvernement prévoit une réduction de
deux points du taux d'épargne des
ménages par rapport à celui de 2022
constatons ensemble que beaucoup de
Français tentent déjà de jongler avec
des consommations subies plus 2,9% pour
l'énergie moins 1,6% de la combustion
alimentaire sur le dernier trimestre
malgré une envolée des prix de près de
10% sur un an
il faut savoir que beaucoup de nos
concitoyens arbitrent entre se chauffer
et manger mais qu'adviendra-t-il ensuite
je vous le dis c'est une source
d'inquiétude majeur pour les
parlementaires communistes une autre
hypothèse est optimiste la hausse des
investissements des entreprises c'est un
pari risqué la question est posée que
lorsqu'on connaît les versements records
de dividendes de la période récente et
je vous le dis avec esprit de
responsabilité au détriment de
l'investissement donc de la relance rien
qu'en 2021
les bénéfices réalisés par les
entreprises du CAC 40 ont atteint un
montant record en 2021 après de 160
milliards d'euros en augmentation je dis
bien en augmentation de
82,9% par rapport à 2019 avant la crise
sanitaire sur ce montant 160 milliards
d'investissements vous les avez vu dans
vos territoires non vous avez eu des
augmentations de salaire dans la plupart
des entreprises concernées par ces
dividendes non pensez-vous plus d'un
tiers 57,5 milliards d'euros sont allés
dans la poche des actionnaires je sais
pas qui est concerné ici en tout cas
celui qui vous parle ne le l'est pas
l'investissement doit être tiré par le
haut par les grandes entreprises
lorsqu'on sait que 2% des entreprises
ayant investi ont généré 87% du montant
des investissements totaux dernier
hypothèse qui ne saurait pas être tenu
malgré une dépréciation historique de la
parité Euro Dollar alors là c'est
l'amélioration de la balance commerciale
le rapport entre importation étant
déficit et je vous le concède messieurs
les ministres il en déficit depuis 2006
ce n'est pas seulement de d'aujourd'hui
et vous cherchez souvent mes chers
collègues à
vous exprimer sur ce qui devrait être un
déficit structurel et bah franchement si
celui-là les postes structurels depuis
2006 chercher en meilleur par contre je
vous le dis tout de suite c'est pas
amandable
je le dis et je répéterai à l'envie ce
texte est d'ores et déjà caduque parce
que les prévisions du gouvernement sont
trop optimistes s'il était respecté ils
mettra en cause des acquis sociaux la
capacité d'intervention de l'État et des
collectivités terroriales territoriales
pour protéger les Français les plus
volnans je vais le résumer comme ça mais
cette loi de programmation c'est
l'antithèse de la formule de Jean Jaurès
belle formule toute la nation sera comme
une immense assemblée possédante et
dirigeante le taux de la croissance
publique sera en moyenne et en volume
des croissantes de moins 0,2% dans le
projet du gouvernement et là je me
tourne sur ma droite et et en écoutant
aussi le rapporteur général grâce à la
droite sénatoriale on va passer à 0,6%.
c'est du jamais vu c'est du jamais vu
nous n'avons connu un tel rétrécissement
de la dépense publique qu'en 2018 mais
ce n'est que parce que les gouvernements
sont dépensés par plaisir personne ne le
pense ici le pire c'est que la baisse
des dépenses publiques est déjà minées
par des restes à payer important et des
engagements de dépenses à la hausse
prévu dans les lois de programmation je
pense aux militaires à l'enseignement
supérieur et d'autres encore qu'il
convient d'honorer les restes à payer
sur le budget de l'État c'est levait à
178,5 milliards en 2021 donc 83
milliards pour les dépenses militaires
par exemple les lois de programmation
elles représentent 115 milliards en 2022
soit 40% des dépenses pilotables pour
chacune des années de 2023 à 2025 elles
feront augmenter la dépense publique à
de 5 à 6 milliards d'euros sur le budget
de l'État il faudra couper ailleurs mais
là je vous pose la question c'est pour
ces sens aussi de cette question de
motion préalable mais où mes chers
collègues va falloir couper sur la
transition et écologique va falloir
couper sur la mission travaillant va
falloir couper sur la mission solidarité
insertion va falloir couper sur
l'enseignement scolaire ou faut couper
d'ailleurs dans tous ces domaines vu
l'ampleur des chiffres
le gouvernement elle mérite et moi je
lui reconnais ce mérite par exemple de
dire ce qu'il va faire perte des crédits
en volume oui il le dit c'est claire au
moins dans le document il va faire
perdre des crédits en volume à
l'Outre-mer il va faire perdre des
crédits au sport et à la jeunesse et la
vie associative c'est tout dit c'est
clair c'est dans l'article 12 s'il
rejette global du texte par cette notion
n'est pas votée nous inviterons
évidemment à supprimer cet article sur
les bancs de nos collègues de droite ou
vous comptez réaliser des économies
supplémentaires dites-nous excusez moi
mais je vous le dis avec beaucoup de
respect mais c'est quand même un peu
peut-être un peu trop facile d'être
libéral quand on parle de dépenses
et d'être très interventionniste quand
vous constatez les besoins dans vos
départements il y a quelque chose qui
est un paradoxe difficile à gérer me
semble-t-il vous consentez mes chers
collègues de droite une fonction des
concours financiers ou collectivités
territoriales c'est l'article 16 plus
2,6 % d'augmentation des dépenses en
valeur c'est une baisse des dotations
d'au moins virgule 4 points l'année
prochaine selon les prévisions
d'inflation dans la même logique
l'article 13 en temps plafonner les
dépenses de fonctionnement des
collectivités territoriales à la louche
pour de toute la même façon c'est à mon
avis je comprends je comprends la
difficulté
de la démocratie empêchant à long terme
de penser les finances publiques dans un
scénario tenable et tenu dans le respect
des engagements pris ce texte comme 11
fois sur les 14 dernières années verra
le déficit dépassé la dette publique
diminuée et la croissance ne pas être au
rendez-vous je vous invite vraiment à
voter cette notion préalable et merci de
m'avoir laissé 45 secondes de plus merci
madame la Présidente et merci à vous de
votre attention
je ne pense pas qu'il y ait
d'inscription pour prendre la parole 10
minutes contre la motion
je vais demander quelle est l'avis de la
commission avant de vous passer la
parole monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur votre avis s'il
vous plaît
évidemment c'est un avis défavorable
j'ai bien expliqué les raisons la
stratégie de notre assemblée je pense
que les Français n'attendent pas de
rajouter du désordre au cas où à la
difficulté
après
l'interruption du texte et son rejet à
l'Assemblée nationale nous avons défini
d'abord je pense qu'on s'inscrit dans un
esprit de responsabilité alors on va
l'entendre effectivement ce mot oui bien
sûr mais effectivement il n'est le
monopole de personnes ça ne pose mais il
y a absolument aucun problème
par contre une fois qu'on a donné cette
nouvelle trajectoire qui est celle d'un
effort partagé parce que il me semble il
nous semble qu'on regarde la situation à
un moment donné nous devons concentrer
nos efforts cibler effectivement les
dépenses que l'État doit consentir et
éventuellement à son côté les bloc des
collectivités locales
et faire ce que j'ai appelé le
parallélisme des exigences parce que là
où il y a une vraiment une injustice
c'est dans la proposition faite par le
gouvernement de s'exonérer des efforts
qu'il demande aux collectivités locales
on va vous le dire pendant plusieurs
heures dans ce débat j'ai entendu que le
gouvernement au moins dans les paroles
et dans les intentions
semblent partager la vie de du Sénat
raison pour laquelle la
motion préalable du groupe communiste et
républicain reçoit un avis défavorable
quelle est la vie du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
la vie a vie défavorable également
j'aurais juste répondre à certaines
remarques qui ont été faites sur notre
réponse au problème immédiat que
l'inflation et nos réponses aux
problèmes structurels de l'économie
française que nous essayons de résoudre
depuis un peu plus de 5 ans sur
l'inflation vous nous parlez de
précarité
c'est une précarité à 100 milliards
d'euros qui ont été dépensés de 2021 à
2023 pour protéger nos compatriotes et
protéger des entreprises contre
l'inflation la vraie précarité
c'est celle qu'on votée vous alliez de
la nupes en supprimant le bouclier
tarifaire sur l'électricité sur le gaz
pour financer une explosion de ma prime
rénov ça c'est 580 euros à débourser
chaque année en moyenne par ménage ça
c'est de la vraie précarité
et si les votes ont un sens et en
démocratie ils en ont un la nupes a voté
la précarité énergétique généralisée
pour nos compatriotes en supprimant le
bouclier énergétique qui protège depuis
près de deux ans nos compatriotes contre
la flambée des électricité et la flambée
des prix du gaz et les votes ont un sens
nous à l'inverse nous avons mis en place
ce bouclier nous avons indexé l'ensemble
des prestations sociales
nous avons indexé le SMIC je rappelle
que nous sommes l'un des seuls pays
européens à voir un salaire minimum qui
est indexé sur l'inflation le seul
salaire qui est augmenté de près de 8%
plus de 8% même c'est le SMIC depuis un
an parce qu'il y a une indexation du
SMIC sur l'augmentation des prix aucun
autre pays européen n'a ce type de
dispositif nous venons de mettre en
place
l'augmentation de 50% monsieur le
sénateur de la location de soutien
familial qui passe à 184 euros qui
touche 800 000 femmes seules enfin si
c'est pas de la lutte contre la
précarité je ne sais pas comment ça
s'appelle mais on peut critiquer par
tous les biens notre politique mais
certainement pas dire que nous ne
luttons pas avec efficacité contre la
précarité nous sommes l'un des seuls
pays en Europe ou malgré la crise du
covid malgré la crise de l'inflation le
taux de pauvreté n'a pas augmenté
14% c'est toujours trop mais c'est mieux
que les autres pays européens c'est
mieux évidemment que les États-Unis ou à
cause de l'inflation à cause de la crise
du covid les inégalités et la pauvreté
ont explosé
s'agissant des salaires je le redis les
entreprises qui le peuvent doivent
augmenter les salaires j'ai augmenté en
moyenne 3,5% depuis le mois de juillet
et j'invite tout seul qui le peuvent à
augmenter les salaires enfin s'agissant
des entreprises nous avons protégé aussi
puisque nous avons mis en place
des mesures à hauteur de 10 milliards
d'euros pour amortir le choc de
l'augmentation des prix de l'électricité
et du gaz sur les entreprises mais je
crois que nos vrais différences et c'est
tout l'intérêt du débat que nous avons
ici c'est sûr le diagnostic que nous
portons sur la situation de l'économie
française et des comptes publics depuis
je dirais trois décennies qu'est-ce qui
caractérise la France depuis trois
décennies et qu'est-ce que nous essayons
de renverser pour opérer cette
révolution économique qui doit donner de
la prospérité de la justice à nos
compatriotes la première chose qui
caractérise la France par quelques boucs
on le prenne c'est que c'est le niveau
de dépenses publiques le plus élevé des
pays européens juste derrière le
Danemark donc si la dépense publique
faisait le bonheur d'une nation la
nation française serait la plus heureuse
de toutes les nations européennes j'ai
peur que ce ne soit pas encore tout à
fait le cas
pour une raison qui est simple c'est que
je pense que les Français estiment à
juste titre
qui n'en n'ont pas pour leur argent
si on regarde ce niveau très élevé de
dépenses publiques il se disait tout va
bien à l'hôpital tout va bien à l'école
tout va bien dans les collèges tout va
bien dans les universités je pense
qu'ils accepteraient ce taux de
prélèvement obligatoire et ce taux de
dépenses publiques très élevé mais comme
ce n'est pas le cas nous devons avec
résolution chercher un meilleur emploi
de la dépense publique une plus grande
efficacité de la dépense publique je
suis le rapport en général soit la
nécessité que l'état donne l'exemple aux
côtés des collectivités locales pour
réduire la dépense publique et avoir une
dépense plus juste et plus efficace
notamment pour nos services publics la
deuxième chose qui caractérise la France
c'est que là aussi avec la majorité avec
Gabriel Attal a été président de la
République avec tous les sénateurs de la
majorité nous avons voulu renverser
comme tendance depuis maintenant plus de
5 ans c'est que nous avons les impôts
les plus élevés de tous les pays
européens juste derrière le Danemark les
chiffres viennent de tomber on a réussi
à les baisser d'un point en moyenne
on a un peu amélioré la situation mais
malgré tout il y a toujours plus
d'impôts toujours plus de taxes toujours
plus de prélèvement obligatoire dans
notre pays qui sont proposés par les uns
pas les autres je voudrais que comme on
disait dans la Bible les écailles
tombent des yeux de certains qu'ils
s'aperçoivent que ce taux de prélèvement
obligatoire est un supportable pour nos
compatriotes qui se disent pourquoi tant
d'impôt pourquoi tant de taxes pourquoi
te rendre prélèvement obligatoire et
pourquoi à chaque fois qu'il y a un
problème vous nous dites augmenter les
impôts augmenter les taxes augmenter les
prélèvements obligatoires je considère
une bonne fois pour toutes que c'est la
mauvaise solution et que si on veut de
la justice fiscale et je veux de la
justice fiscale aidez-moi soit taxation
des géants du numérique aidez-moi soit
taxation minimale à l'impôt sur les
sociétés et des mois pourquoi pas sur la
taxation de l'utilisation des
infrastructures numériques par les
géants du digital et des mois sur le
prélèvement que nous faisons de la rente
des énergéticiens qui nous rapporter 26
milliards d'euros ça c'est de la vraie
justice n'allez pas chercher l'argent
dans la poche des Français ce n'est plus
la solution et d'ailleurs je considère
que ça ne l'a jamais véritablement été
enfin le dernier point sur lequel nous
serons en désaccord c'est sur le volume
global de travail le volume global de
travail en France est insuffisant par
rapport aux autres grandes nations
européennes et petit à petit par quoi
est-ce que ça se traduit par un
appauvrissement relatif de la France par
rapport aux autres grandes nations
européennes donc oui il faut avoir le
courage de baisser les impôts oui il
faut voir le courage de réduire la
pression fiscale oui il faut avoir le
courage de réduire la dépense publique
pour que nos services publics auxquels
je tiens autant que vous soient bien
financé et oui il faut avoir le courage
d'engager une réforme des retraites avec
le souci de la justice du respect des
carrières longues du respect de la
pénibilité des métiers mais tout
simplement pour accroître le volume
global de travail qui fera
l'approchephérité de en France et
l'approche périphérique des Français
merci y a-t-il d'autres explications de
vote
je n'en vois pas je vais donc consulter
le Sénat sur la motion pendant à poser à
opposer la question préalable je
rappelle que l'adoption de cette motion
entraînerait le rejet du texte en
discussion
avis défavorable de la commission avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui vote
pour
qui vote pour Monsieur ça vole Delhi
oui
mais ce serait bien de lever voilà si
vous pouviez exprimer vos votes voilà
merci qui votre contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
nous poursuivons donc la discussion
générale la parole est à Monsieur
Christian BIAC du groupe RDS pour 5
minutes chers collègues
madame la Présidente mais je suis les
ministres madame la rapporteur je suis
le rapporteur général monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
mes chers collègues
l'Assemblée nationale dont rejeté le
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques pour 2003
2027 c'est quelque chose d'inédit et les
conséquences d'un rejet définitif sont
difficiles évalués les sans craindre le
non versement de fonds européen à la
France
les objectifs des lois de programmation
budgétaires ont rarement été respectés
par le passé et je ne serai pas surpris
que ce texte comme les précédents soit
un exercice imposé plutôt que de
feuilles de route et ce malgré les
nouvelles à disposition de gégatives
si je partage la volonté de redresser
les comptes publics je regrette que ce
projet repousse en toute fin de période
le retour attendu plus de rapidité
serait me semble-t-il nécessaire
ce texte répond aussi au calendrier
budgétaire européen et aux engagements
pris par la phrase maison de là certains
principes préventes et en citer
permanence France lors de l'examen du
projet de loi de règlement du budget et
d'approbation des comptes 2021 je
rappelle que les comptes en désordre
sont la marque des nations qui
s'abandonnent je rappelle aussi que les
paysans disent qu'il convient de
dépenser moins est-ce que ce que l'on
gagne et de faire des économies en
prévision des mauvaises récoltes à venir
c'est le simple bon sens
mais revenons sur les principales
dispositions du texte l'article premier
prévoit l'approbation du rapport annexé
avec ces hypothèses macroéconomiques et
de croissance sur cinq ans soit 1,7 par
an sauf 1% en 2083
prévoyant de réduire le déficit
structurel et la poursuite et baisse des
impôts table à un sur des taux d'intérêt
de 2 6 à court terme et trois à long
terme en 2027 ce scénario me semble
plutôt optimiste
la situation financière de notre pays
est pour le moins préoccupante mais à
votre décharge messieurs les ministres
je dois convenir que la crise sanitaire
la guerre à l'Ukraine et maintenant la
crue énergétique son grandement
responsables de la situation j'espère et
nous espérons tous revenir rapidement à
une situation qui pourra être qualifiée
normal même si la géopolitique n'apporte
pas un vent d'optimisme
afin de réduire le déficit j'aurais mes
numéros à trois chiffres et fort des
administrations de sécurité sociale 27
milliards d'euros
effort des administrations locales 25
milliards d'euros et fort de l'État
administration centrale 0 €
le responsable fait donc payer les
autres et en particulier les
collectivités locales qui ne sont
aucunement responsables du déficit
puisqu'elles ont l'obligation de voter
des budgets en équilibre
la progression de départ de
fonctionnement doit rester inférieure à
l'inflation moins 0,5 mais comment
réussir le côté actuel
et les collectivités
n'atteignant par Objectif riche collège
plus jeune des subventions de l'État
le texte issu de la Commission ne va pas
fait changer d'avis cette loi de
programmation ne programme rien du tout
je regrette qu'elle ne prévoit pas un
partage de responsabilité avec leurs
locaux qui ont fait leur preuve sur le
terrain ce serait utile pour l'État qui
doit se concentrer sur ces millions et
sur ces nichons réaliennes dont les
moyens sont notoirement insuffisants
plutôt que de s'entêter à te faire tout
seul quand on fait tout on fait tout mal
à quand une nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation
en ce qui concerne les administrations
de sécurité sociale le projet de loi
prévoit 25 milliards d'économies
le gouvernement table sur la réforme des
retraites pour réduire le déficit mais
chacun sait qu'elle ne portera pas ses
fruits avant l'exécution de cette loi de
programmation pourtant les besoins sont
immenses dans la branche maladie avec
les déserts médicaux qui se multiplient
les urgences saturées la fermeture des
lignes voir l'établissement mais aussi
dans la brèche autonomie avec une
association alarmante des EHPAD et en
particulier des EHPAD public ce ne sont
pas les 3700 créations de postes prévues
au PLFSS 2023 qui vont régler le
problème cela représente la création
d'un demi poste par établissement
pour conclure ce texte traduit une
gestion molle des finances publiques les
crédits semblent aussi balancer comme
les feuilles mortes au gré du vent et
comme elle a écrit Sénèque hallucilius
il n'est pas devant favorable pour celui
qui ne sait où il va c'est pourquoi je
voterai personnellement contre ce projet
de loi programmation les membres du
groupe rdce conformément à notre
position traditionnelle
détermineront leur vote en fonction des
débats je vous remercie merci Charles
collègue la parole est à présent Madame
Christine lazarde pour le gros blé
républicains vous avez 8 minutes chers
collègues
monsieur le ministre le 13 juillet
devant la commission des finances du
Sénat le premier président de la Cour
des comptes président du Haut Conseil
des finances publiques préconisés
d'établir une loi de programmation
crédible et globale c'est-à-dire avec
des hypothèses réalistes des mesures
d'économie détaillées articuler avec les
lois de programmation sectorielle ne
reportant pas l'effort en fin de période
et associant l'ensemble des acteurs
publics le gouvernement ne semble pas
avoir fait sciences mantra tout d'abord
le Conseil des finances publiques et les
analyses économiques considèrent les
hypothèses macroéconomiques improbables
la vie du Haut Conseil relève que la
trajectoire de la LPF repose sur trois
hypothèses favorables soit un mouvement
de désépargne des ménages au troisième
trimestre la croissance de la
consommation est de 0% après 0,3 au
deuxième le maintien à niveau élevé de
l'investissement des entreprises et
enfin une contribution positive du
commerce extérieur au troisième
trimestre elle est négative à -05 poids
permettez-nous donc d'avoir des doutes
série sur la possibilité que ces trois
critères soient réunis pendant les 5
prochaines années au regard des
dernières données publiées par l'Insee
dans son dernier repère l'Institut
exécone écrit que si des perspectives de
croissance du PIB plus prudente mais
sans doute plus vraisemblable se
réaliser le déficit public ne se
résorberait pas et la dette publique
continuerait d'augmenter en pourcentage
du PIB pour atteindre 120% en 2027 ceci
montre combien la trajectoire est
sensible à son point de départ dans ces
perspectives sur l'économie mondiale
d'octobre le FMI anticipe que plus de la
moitié des pays de la zone euro
connaîtront une réception technique cet
hiver la France est relativement
épargnée puisque le même institut table
sur une croissance de 0,7% pour 2023 en
deçà cependant de l'hypothèse du
gouvernement
malgré une anticipation très optimiste
de la croissance le déficit reste de 5%
et ne retrouve son niveau de 3% qu'en
2027 nous serions donc pendant deux ans
les plus mauvaises élèves de la zone
euro mais ce chiffre de 5% fait oublier
tous les ordres de grandeur le
déséquilibre des finances publiques est
plutôt de 45%, le PLF dont nous
discuterons prévoir bientôt prévoit 500
milliards de dépenses contre 345
milliards de recettes la maîtrise des
dépenses publiques est pourtant devenue
un totem combien de fois avons-nous
entendu que le temps du quoi qu'il en
coûte et derrière nous que maintenant
nous sommes à l'Europe je vous cite
qu'il s'agit désormais de décider en
fonction du combien ça coûte or les
dépenses courantes augmentent de 62
milliards dans le PLF déposé le 26
septembre et depuis cette date plusieurs
dépenses nouvelles ont déjà été
annoncées hausse du bonus écologique
élargissement du bouclier tarifaire et
tant d'autres la baisse du ratio de la
dépense publique inscrite dans la
programmation repose en grande partie
sur la disparition progressive des
dépenses exceptionnelles soit encore 61
milliards en 2022 concernant la dépense
courante le rapporteur général l'a
rappelé la trajectoire suis celle des
dépenses publiques du quinquennat
précédente 140 milliards en plus
l'objectif de moyen terme de sol de
structurel fixé par l'article 5 d'un
règlement européen de 1997 ne sera pas
atteint pendant l'ensemble du
quinquennat il sera au mieux égal à la
moitié de l'effort attendu soit 0,3
points par an de 2024 à 2027
l'insuffisance de réduction du déficit
structurel souligne le manque
d'engagement de réforme les mêmes
réformes reviennent dans les PNR
successifs toujours aussi peu documentés
en premier lieu la réforme des retraites
l'état demande des efforts aux Français
et aux collectivités territoriales qui
ne s'imposent pas à lui-même l'effort
exigé des a pull n'a jamais été atteint
au cours des 40 dernières années
pourtant le rapporteur général à
l'Assemblée nationale genre René
Cazeneuve a reconnu que la situation
sera difficile pour les collectivités
territoriales l'année prochaine et elle
le sera aussi pour l'État français pour
les entreprises et pour tout le monde
sur le site toujours il faut partager
cet effort entre les différentes
administrations c'est une question de
responsabilité l'effort que nous
demandons à l'état qui vient d'être
exposé par le rapporteur général et
toutes choses égales par ailleurs plus
faibles que pour les collectivités en
effet l'indice des dépenses communales
ou encore le panier du maire estimé sur
le premier semestre 2022 fait apparaître
une évolution de 4,8% sur 4 trimestres
glissants sur la même période l'indice
des prix à la consommation hors tabac
n'avait progressé que de 3,4%. le
différentiel c'est encore accru au cours
des deuxièmes et 3e trimestre par
ailleurs plusieurs textes législatifs
récents comprennent les budgets locaux à
plus ou moins long terme en tout premier
lieu la loi climat est résilience d'août
2021 c'est un effort nécessaire auquel
les collectivités sont prêtes encore
faut-il qu'elles en ait les moyens la
maîtrise de la dépense publique ne se
décrète pas
construit dans la durée Gérard Longuet
reviendra sur cette thématique en
illustrant avec des politiques publiques
c'est parce que vous nier cette réalité
que vous avez imposé aux grandes
collectivités les contrats de Cahors
vous vous êtes félicité des résultats
alors même que ce n'est que la
conséquence des efforts de gestion
rendue nécessaire par la contraction des
concours financiers de l'État sur la
période 2014-2017 le gouvernement
indique avoir conçu un nouveau
dispositif les contrats de confiance
comment osez-vous dire que le dispositif
est différent alors que l'article 23 est
partiellement à copier-coller de
l'article 29 de la précédente LPF les
collectivités sont tenues de présenter
un budget en équilibre elle ne participe
donc pas à la dérive de nos comptes
publics contrairement à l'état qui cette
année encore va devoir financer 158
milliards d'euros de déficit et en
comptant les refinancements 270
milliards de dettes par ailleurs la
référence retenue est mauvaise c'est sur
la base de l'autofinancement et non pas
de la dépense que s'effectue le pilotage
financier des collectivités locales
ce dernier permet la couverture des
dotations amortissements et de financer
les investissements messieurs le
ministre l'effort demandé à l'état est
réaliste nos collègues de l'Assemblée
nationale dont la continuité des travaux
de parlementaire de la majorité vous ont
proposé de passer d'un état bedonnant et
malvoyant à un état élancé et
clairvoyant en vingt ans le nombre de
décrets d'applications a augmenté de
310% en 2019 le Conseil d'évaluation des
normes évaluer le coût des obligations
relatives à 790 millions d'euros pour
les collectivités atteindre la moyenne
des pays de l'OCDE pour le ratio coûte
production des services publics sur le
PIB permettrait de dégager 84 milliards
d'économies dans une autre récente lui
frappe estime la charge administrative
de 12 à 25 milliards pour les
collectivités les services publics et
les particuliers cet effort réaliste est
indispensable si nous souhaitons faire
refluer notre endettement dans la
programmation du gouvernement la dette
ne serait tuée qu'à partir de 2026
uniquement grâce aux excéd budgétaires
des apules et des assos comme
l'ajustement souligné Elisabeth Doisneau
rapporteur pour la commission des
affaires sociales la trajectoire de
l'ONDAM apparaît fragile et parfois
d'une crédibilité discutable dans leur
sagesse des membres de cette commission
notamment dès le texte afin que le
compteur des écarts trouve à s'appliquer
à toutes les lois de financement de la
sécurité sociale jusqu'en 2027 les
Français doivent prendre conscience que
le gouvernement fait vivre le pays avec
une épée de Damoclès un biais optimise
dans les projections de finances
publiques devient problématique dès lors
que les conditions de financement de la
dette sont plus dépendantes des marchés
dans un environnement rendu moins
favorable au financement des dettes
publiques par le resserrement de la
politique monétaires un déficit de
crédibilité peut induire une prime de
risque qui viendrait augmenter la charge
de la dette et par conséquent
contraindre le financement de l'action
publique cette prophétie pourrait
malheureusement se réaliser après plus
0,5 points juillet plus 0,75 points en
septembre jeudi dernier la bceo a
augmenté s'est taux directeur des 0,75
points le taux des eaux at à 10 ans a
dépassé 100% le 21 octobre alors qu'il
était encore négatif en décembre 2021
pour toutes ces raisons le groupe les
républicains soutient le taxe issu des
travaux de la commission des finances
vous aurez d'ailleurs noté notre
sobriété en matière de dépôt
d'amendement car la trajectoire
consignit 4 objectifs réduire le déficit
et l'endettement public plus rapidement
que dans la programmation du
gouvernement assurer la pleine
contribution des administrations
centrales préserver les dépenses
sociales et régaliennes conserver des
marges d'intervention dans un contexte
ou une crise en chasse une autre les
deux ministres nous ont appelé à être
responsables avec cette LPF amendée nous
le sommes
merci la parole est à présent à notre
collègue le sénateur Emmanuel Capu pour
le groupe des indépendants et vous avez
5 minutes chers collègues
madame la Présidente messieurs les mini
à monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général madame la
rapporteur
mes chers collègues il y a trois cas de
figure où l'on refuse de se fixer un
objectif le premier c'est lorsqu'on est
pas sûr de l'atteindre le deuxième c'est
lorsqu'on est sûr de ne pas l'atteindre
et le troisième c'est lorsqu'on veut
rien atteindre du tout
je me réjouis que la commission des
finances du Sénat considère que nous ne
sommes dans aucun de ces cas on
choisissant d'amander le texte nous nous
mettons dans l'objectif dans l'optique
de fixer un objectif clair pour nos
finances publiques c'est une démarche
responsable qui fait honneur à notre
chambre notre groupe la soutient
pleinement
à l'Assemblée nationale les oppositions
se sont liguées n'ont pas pour amender
le texte elles sont incapables de
trouver un accord mais pour le rejeter
en bloc je regrette ce qu'elle cède à
l'appel du chaos comme la rappeler le
rapporteur général plutôt que de
s'accorder sur une programmation qui
donne de la visibilité à nos finances
publiques
bien sûr il est toujours possible
d'améliorer un texte nous avons
d'ailleurs déposé plusieurs amendements
afin de renonc de renforcer trois
ambitions du projet porté par le
gouvernement la première de ces
ambitions c'est la maîtrise des dépenses
publiques je salue la démarche du
gouvernement qui présente une
trajectoire qui ramène le déficit sous
la barre des 3 % du pays B à horizon
2027 ce n'est ni une obsession ni une
lubie c'est simplement un engagement que
nous avait que nous avons pris vis-à-vis
de nos partenaires européens vous l'avez
parfaitement bien rappelé monsieur le
ministre lors des débats pour la
modernisation de la lol il y a un an
notre groupe avait toutefois fait
adopter un abandonnement pour préciser
que le projet de loi de programmation
dans son rapport annexé devait présenter
une comparaison européenne cette
comparaison a défaut d'être réjouissante
est éclairante tous les autres États ont
adopté une loi de programmation et tous
de la graisse au Portugal en passant par
l'Italie et l'Espagne tout sont prévus
de repasser sous la barre des 3% d'ici
tout sauf nous qui attendrons 2027 c'est
pourquoi nous avons présenté plusieurs
amendements visant à encadrer plus
fortement les dépenses de l'État qui
portent l'essentiel du déficit et de la
dette mais Monsieur le Ministre les
chiffres sont clairs pour rétablir nos
comptes nos efforts doivent porter
principalement sur les administrations
centrales c'est une question d'équité
d'efficacité de ce point de vue les
propositions de la commission des
finances me paraissent intéressantes
nous a relats occasion dans débattre
plus longuement tout à l'heure et
Monsieur le Maire tout à l'heure avant
son départ avait à juste titre rappelé
que les propositions qui étaient faites
étaient bonnes et honnêtes
la seconde ambition que nous souhaitons
renforcer c'est le verdissement du
budget il s'agit d'un levier
indispensable pour accélérer la
transition écologique nous avons fait
adopter en commission un amendement pour
le budget général nous vous ont
proposerons un autre pour engager une
telle dynamique au sein des
collectivités locales
la troisième ambition c'est le respect
des libertés locales l'article 23 il
faut le rappeler et bien meilleur que la
baisse brutale des dotations imposées
sous le sous la présidence du président
Hollande
mais vous savez monsieur le ministre que
c'est un sujet de préoccupation du Sénat
les collectivités ne sont pas
responsables de l'aggravation de notre
déficit public et de notre dette en 2021
elles ont même dégagé près de 5
milliards d'euros d'excédents elle ne
représente que 7% d'endettement public
et 20% de la dépense publique monsieur
le ministre notre groupe partage votre
ambition et votre stratégie nous savons
les efforts que vous déployez pour
maintenir le cap en temps de crise tout
en soutenant les ménages les entreprises
et les collectivités mais nous restons
particulièrement vigilant quand
l'autonomie financière des collectivités
j'espère donc que nous trouverons une
solution pour donner des gages à nos
partenaires européens sans contraindre
excessivement les collectivités il faut
éviter de monter l'état contre les
collectivités la crise nous l'a rappelé
les collectivités ont besoin de l'État
et l'État a besoin des collectivités
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à présent à Monsieur
Daniel Daniel pardon Breuillet du groupe
écologiste vous avez 5 minutes chers
collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur général monsieur le Président
de la Commission messieurs les ministres
chers collègues
pensez l'avenir c'est l'idée que l'on se
fait d'une loi de programmation je ne
parle pas ici de bouclier nécessaire
même lorsqu'ils sont mal ciblés ni
d'orthodoxie budgétaire réaffirmé et
amplifier sous le nom de sérieux
budgétaire mais bien de penser l'avenir
et notamment le bouleversement
climatique et les désordres qu'il va
induire
les moyens de l'indispensable mutation
pour y répondre ce n'est pas possible en
poursuivant le désarmement financier de
l'État et la mise au pain sec des
collectivités entendez les scientifiques
messieurs les ministres la dette
climatique coûte écoutera plus cher que
la dette financière chaque année
d'inaction ou de petits pas nous
condamnent à devoir faire face à des
sécheresses durables et étendues des
inondations des canicules des incendies
des tempêtes qui détruisent des villages
entiers bio-cour dans le Pas-de-Calais
osanis encore après la Roya et avant qui
ce sera de plus en plus dur et de plus
en plus douloureux mais d'abord pour les
plus modestes d'entre nous sur le plan
social cette loi de programmation est
libérale elle est encore durcie par la
volonté de la majorité sénatoriale
de coupe massive des dépenses publiques
et de réduction accélérée de la dette
cela fait courir le risque au pays de
basculer dans la récession l'aggravation
du sentiment d'injustice et
l'effondrement continue des services
publics l'hôpital l'école les
universités l'Office National des Forêts
temps de service public sont déjà à la
peine mais 5 minutes qui me sont
accordés ne suffirait pas à les citer
pourtant cette entêtement de baisse des
prélèvements obligatoires a réussi sur
un point par le passé c'est la hausse
record des dividendes nous avons le
triste record d'Europe triste à mon sens
quand la France entière fait des
kilomètres de queue à la pompe pour
payer un carburant trop cher au
détriment d'autres dépenses essentielles
comment accepter qu'une entreprise comme
Total énergie dégage 6,6 milliards de
bénéfices au troisième trimestre 2022
c'est indécent pour les salariés comme
pour les citoyens comme le sont les
presque 60 milliards de versées par le
CAC 40 l'an passé dans notre pays car
oui il y a de l'argent total et
l'illustration
ultime et caricaturale du système que
vous soutenez mordicus la baisse de la
contribution des plus aisées n'est pas
plus acceptable car l'impôt reste
l'outil indispensable d'une société
juste et civilisée c'est pourquoi les
écologistes refusent la suppression de
la CVAE revendique une taxation des
dividendes supérieures à celle du
travail et propose un ISF climatique
c'est un encouragement à être vertueux
et solidaire qui repose sur l'inclusion
dans le calcul de l'impôt des plus
fortunés d'un malus assis sur
l'empreinte carbone de leur patrimoine
financier nous vous proposons aussi la
création d'une loi de programmation plus
réelle des financements de la transition
écologique qui assurait une meilleure
visibilité aux entreprises au ménage aux
investisseurs comme aux collectivités
territoriales
pour les entreprises il serait de bon
sens que l'octroi des aides publiques
soit systématiquement conditionnés à des
contreparties sociales et écologiques il
y a urgence
urgence aussi pour les collectivités
vous ne cessez de diminuer le autonomie
et la capacité à agir des communes vous
ne les protégez pas ou pas assez face à
l'inflation et aux couches spéculatifs
de l'énergie vous leur avez retiré la
quasi-totalité vous et vos prédécesseurs
de leur pouvoir fiscaux mais ça ne vous
suffit pas vous voulez aussi contrôler
leurs dépenses la réduction des charges
de fonctionnement n'est plus chez vous
du domaine de l'entêtement mais de
l'obsession surtout quand il s'agit des
charges de fonctionnement des autres
baisser le fonctionnement cela signifie
cesser d'accueillir les tout-petits dans
les crèches les enfants à la cantine
fermer des médiathèques des espaces
culturels des équipements sportifs des
centres de loisirs ou encore des centres
de santé dont vous étiez pourtant
satisfaits qu'ils permettent la
vaccination de tout le monde voit la
quelques mois rien ne le justifie car
les collectivités sont gérées sainement
sans déficit contrairement à notre étage
à Cobain et avec un fort investissement
utile à l'ensemble du pays vous devriez
au contraire soutenir les collectivités
elles sont le laboratoire innovant de
nombreuses politiques publiques
nécessaires pour la transition elles
sont enfin en cette période de crise un
rempart démocratique que sur tous les
bancs nous devrions soutenir et
respecter il faut miser sur elle avec
résilience elle gère le quotidien et
construisent l'avenir c'est ce que nous
attendons des lois de programmation et
c'est pourquoi nous ne voterons pas
celle-ci
merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent à Monsieur Didier Rambaud
sénateur du groupe RDPI vous avez 6
minutes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre monsieur les
présidents de commission mes chers
collègues nous sommes aujourd'hui devant
un choix décisif qui engagera notre
responsabilité pour les 5 années qui
viennent et en cela c'est même de
l'avenir de notre pays et de ses
finances que nous sommes amenés à
discuter cela fait des mois que le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques nous
affirme qu'il sera nécessaire de
modifier les règles communes du pack de
stabilité européen mais quel que soit la
souplesse qui sera apportée pour
permettre aux États d'affronter les
crises avec une politique contraceptique
ambitieuse il est impératif que nous
gardions le cap de des 3% de déficit
réduire la dette doit également être un
cas prioritaire en sortie de crise car
depuis le début des années 2000 cette
dette n'a jamais décrue décrue tout
gouvernement confondu l'ampleur des deux
crises survenu depuis 2007 n'y est pas
étrangère lorsque le monde s'est arrêté
en 2020 l'État a soutenu l'économie les
collectivités locales et les Français au
prix d'un effort budgétaire sans
précédent dont nous devons faut pas
oublier le poids pourra considérable qui
rappelle à redresser le cap en sortie de
crise nous avons une trajectoire fixée
dans le cas du programme de stabilité
qui nous engage vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires européens le devoir de
responsabilité qui doit nous abîmer les
locaux le connaissent bien c'est celui
qui anime les mers au quotidien dans la
gestion de leur compte si nous
poursuivons la trajectoire fixée par le
gouvernement nous tiendrons l'objectif
de 5% de déficit l'an prochain après
avoir tenu l'objectif pour cette année
et nous serons revenus sous les 3% en
2027 la trajectoire a présenté par le
gouvernement prévoyait de diminuer la
dépense publique de 2,6% volume en 2023
en part de PIB elle doit passer de
57,6% à 56,6% l'an prochain est tombé à
53,8% en 2027 c'est l'effort le plus
soutenu depuis 20 ans certains à ma
droite affirment pourtant que l'effort
n'est pas suffisant que les réformes
structurelles qui cet efforts ne sont
pas assez documentés permettez-moi de
vous rappeler que ce n'est pas une loi
de programmation d'inscrire dans la dans
le marbre ni le calendrier ni les
modalités des réformes à venir c'est
frustrant j'en conviens mais nous devons
fixer un cap pas préempté ce qu'il
appartiendra au gouvernement et à la
discussion parlementaire du fixer en
temps voulu j'ajoute également que nous
avons des éléments sur les réformes à
venir la réforme des retraites devrait
pouvoir aboutir dès l'été 2023 pour ce
qui est de l'assurance chômage il
appartient désormais à la commission
mixte paritaire de se prononcer monsieur
le rapport en général j'ai tenais à vous
citer l'ensemble des réformes
structurelles évoquées par le
gouvernement soit absolument nécessaire
nous avons besoin d'une réforme de
retraite nous avons besoin de renforcer
le taux d'activité des seniors nous
avons besoin de réformer le
fonctionnement de l'assurance chômage et
du service public de l'emploi pour
réduire le taux de chômage Vous réclamez
une réforme des retraites plus
importante que celle annoncé par le
président de la République sans nous
dire au juste ce que vous entendez par
là l'instant d'avant vous nous disiez
que les contours du projet potentiel
n'était pas clair il faut récemment je
m'interroge aussi sur vos propos en
commission vous avez détaillé un grand
renfort de chiffres et de et de
graphique que les effets des réformes du
gouvernement sur la croissance et le
déficit serait surestimé et sous
documenté et l'instant d'après vous
précisez que la trajectoire apparaît peu
ambitieuse chers collègues de la
majorité sénatoriale pour vous pourriez
vous alors nous expliquer comment vous
comptez procéder pour aller plus loin je
constate en réalité que toute cette
apparente radicalité vole en éclat
lorsqu'il s'agit des collectivités
locales vous validez la trajectoire des
concours financiers aux collectivités
locales prévues par le gouvernement et
c'est tant mieux vous nous dites que les
collectivités territoriales ont pris
leur part dans le redressement des
comptes publics au cours des derniers
quinquennat c'est exact dans le
précédent quinquennat l'État a pris plus
que sa part pour protéger les
collectivités face à la crise le déficit
des collectivités en 2020 étaient à 0,15
quand celui de l'État et de de sécurité
sociale s'est envolée à 8,8 points dès
2021 certaines collectivités ont
retrouvé des marges excédentaires quand
l'État a continué d'absorber le choc
c'est le choix courageux que nous avons
fait dans le contexte actuel chacun doit
prendre sa part des erreurs du passé et
contribuer au rétablissement des comptes
de la Nation je partage cependant votre
inquiétude sur les fortes incertitudes
face à l'inflation et la crise
énergétique les dépenses de
fonctionnement des collectivités sont
terriblement contraintes et nous pouvons
nous interroger sur la soutenabilité
d'une trajectoire à 5 ans si l'inflation
venait à dépasser les seuils de
référence monsieur ministre je compte
sur vous pour nous rassurer dans cette
hypothèse sur la souplesse du mécanisme
que vous réintroduisez à l'article 23 le
dispositif permet par ailleurs de
répondre aux principales critiques qui
ont été formulés à propos des contrats
de Cahors et sous réserve de cette
précision je soutiendrai son
rétablissement avec du nouveau
dispositif qui ne concerne je rappelle
que les collectivités dans le budget
dépassent les 40 millions d'euros soit à
peu près 500 collectivités de notre pays
les objectifs seront fixés par strat et
après un an nous vérifierons si la
strate a atteint son objectif c'est donc
a priori une relation de confiance
puisque les mesures de correction qui
s'imposent n'interviendront que si les
objectifs ne sont pas un temps et je
rappelle que intercommunalité de France
a salué ce dispositif l'Association des
départements de France également sous
réserve de certains aménagements qui
devraient être retenus le gouvernement
aurait pu comme sous le quinquennat
Sarkozy rognait peu à peu sur la DGF
jusqu'à son gel brutal en 2011 nous
aurions pu comme sur le quinquennat
Hollande sabré dans la DGF qui a baissé
je vous rappelle de 12,5 milliards
d'euros mais au contraire en proposant
pour la première fois depuis 13 ans
d'augmenter la DGF de 320 millions
d'euros au PLF 2023 le gouvernement le
choix de la confiance un choix que le
groupe RDPI soutiendra chers collègues
la parole est à présent à Monsieur Rémi
Féraud sénateur du groupe socialiste
vous avez 9 minutes de temps de parole
chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
chers collègues il y a 5 ans
intervenants au nom du groupe socialiste
sur le même document qui trace les
perspectives budgétaires du quinquennat
notre collègue Thierry arsenac alerté
sur plusieurs points essentiels qui les
relevaient
l'injustice fiscale et sociale des
mesures annoncées les relations déjà
dégradées de l'État avec les
collectivités territoriales et le manque
criant de soutien au service public de
notre pays en étudiant la loi de
programmation des finances publiques qui
nous intéressent aujourd'hui je crois
que rien n'a fondamentalement changé
dans la politique menée sauf que vous
n'avez pas trouvé cette fois une
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale pour la
prouver et surtout la loi de
programmation présentée ne tire pas les
enseignements des cinq années
précédentes ainsi la crise des gilets
jaunes a montré et avec quelle acuité la
nécessité de renforcer la présence des
services publics sur l'ensemble du
territoire ainsi que l'enjeu crucial du
pouvoir d'achat et de la justice sociale
la crise sanitaire a mis en lumière les
défaillances de notre système de santé
et bouleversé l'économie mondiale le
retour de la guerre en Europe a entravé
la reprise de l'activité et amplifier
l'inflation qui pousse nombre de nos
concitoyens dans la difficulté ou dans
la pauvreté la remontée des taux
d'intérêt à commencer et personne ne
sait où elle s'arrêtera et enfin la
politique du ruissellement et de plus en
plus largement reconnu comme un échec
jusqu'à la Maison Blanche désormais mais
malgré tout malgré l'accumulation de
crise et l'accroissement des inégalités
dans notre pays malgré l'impréparation
écologique malgré les alertes sur l'état
de nos finances publiques ce projet de
loi ce projet de loi de programmation
confirme l'orientation libérale choisie
par le gouvernement depuis cinq ans et
il faut le reconnaître totalement
assumer il poursuit le mouvement de
désarmement fiscal et une maîtrise entre
guillemets de la dépense publique qui
est la conséquence de la pauvrissement
de l'État tout en restant pourtant
toujours insuffisante aux yeux de la
majorité sénatoriale votre politique
budgétaire monsieur le ministre celle
que vous prévoyez pour les 5 prochaines
années elle met à notre avis en péril à
la fois le redressement de nos services
publics et les marges de manœuvre des
collectivités locales déjà fortement mis
à mal
que ce soit pour les collectivités
territoriales ou l'hôpital public ce ne
sont pas simplement les Ségur ou le
pacte de confiance que vous proposez qui
leur permettront de sortir la tête de
long et qu'en est-il pour les salaires
des enseignants et leur augmentation si
urgentes qu'en est-il pour les
investissements dans le ferroviaire
qu'en est-il pour l'investissement dans
la rénovation énergétique la liste des
besoins est longues et le tableau que
dresse le gouvernement sur les
différentes missions budgétaires restent
entièrement centré sur les missions
relevant du régalien qui ont besoin de
moyens supplémentaires mais les chiffres
sont d'autant plus inquiétant sur
l'ensemble des autres missions surtout
lorsqu'on tient compte de l'inflation
nous pensons au contraire que pour
sortir par le haut des crises
économiques sociales écologiques
démocratique actuelle notre pays devrait
répondre avec volontarisme à trois
grands enjeux réduire les inégalités de
revenus et surtout de patrimoine
redonner de la force à nos services
publics qui se sont en dégradés et
accélérer la transition écologique en
mobilisant beaucoup plus de moyens à cet
effet pourquoi n'en avez-vous pas les
moyens pourquoi la dette budgétaire et
la dette climatique continuent de
gonfler toutes les deux parallèlement
et bien parce qu'en disant les
gouvernements successifs d'Emmanuel
Macron auront organisé la perte de près
de 400 milliards d'euros de recettes
pour l'État si on intègre les annonces
qui sont faites pour ce quinquennat cela
représente une moyenne de 39 milliards
d'euros par an à titre de comparaison si
on prend le chiffre du budget 2023 fin
du projet de budget c'est deux fois
ennemi le budget du ministère de
l'Écologie et votre politique de baisse
des impôts elle se révèle un puissant
fond le ministre Bruno Le Maire l'a
d'ailleurs dit lui-même tout à l'heure à
demi-mots il en faut toujours plus et
qui devra payer les nouvelles mesures
fiscales favorables aux entreprises
comme la suppression de la CVAE
puisqu'elle est entièrement elle devient
automatiquement une dépense
supplémentaire de l'État et bien ce sont
les Français les mêmes français qui ont
déjà compensé depuis cinq ans les
baisses des impôts de production la
suppression de l'ISF la mise en place de
la flat taxe pour les revenus du capital
etc
car pour équilibrer le budget après
toutes ces réductions d'impôts au profit
des entreprises des plus aisées et des
détenteurs du capital le gouvernement
est bien contraint de mettre à
contribution tous les Français et aussi
les collectivités territoriales et aussi
les bailleurs sociaux et aussi les
chômeurs en faisant passer une réforme
de l'assurance chômage qui pénalise les
plus fragiles et surtout désormais le
gouvernement engage une réforme du
régime des retraites que nous
considérons à la fois
inutiles et injuste vous souhaitez ainsi
prolonger l'âge de départ à la retraite
le reporté pardon dans le seul but de
réaliser des économies 8 à 9 milliards
d'euros estimés sur cinq ans fini la
réforme des retraites dites systémiques
dont on nous parlait dans le précédent
quinquennat qui était présenté comme une
mesure d'équité de progrès etc elle n'a
plus aujourd'hui la réforme des
retraites qu'un seul objectif et il est
comptable bouché les trous de votre
politique de l'offre menée un marche
forcée ce sera le rôle de la gauche de
le dire tout au long du quinquennat
qu'une autre politique est possible
remettant les choses à l'endroit ne
privant pas l'état de recettes
indispensables redonnant à notre pays
les moyens de ses ambitions sans
aggraver le déficit public par le
rétablissement d'une fiscalité équitable
entre les revenus du capital et du
travail par la réduction progressive des
niches fiscales qui devrait être
évaluées conditionné pour être maintenu
par l'arrêt des baisses d'impôts dont
nous n'avons pas les moyens encore moins
avec la remontée rapide des taux
d'intérêt et par la mise en place sans
attendre d'une taxation exceptionnelle
sur les super profits enfin cette loi de
programmation elle souffre d'un manque
de crédibilité beaucoup diront que c'est
la loi du genre et qu'aucune loi de
programmation de des finances publiques
n'est jamais respectée mais en
l'occurrence dans son entêtement à
vouloir réduire le taux de prélèvement
obligatoire et surtout à refuser de
faire participer à l'effort national les
plus riches et les grandes entreprises
le gouvernement ne parvient pas dès le
départ à établir une stratégie
convaincante de rétablissement des
comptes publics c'est le Haut Conseil
des finances publiques qui le dit
lui-même en qualifiant la trajectoire de
peu ambitieuse et particulièrement
fragile car elle s'appuie sur des
hypothèses très et donc trop optimistes
alors en commission la majorité
sénatoriale a certes un peu modifié la
trajectoire en l'aggravant de notre
point de vue sur les dépenses mais elle
n'a pas révélé de désaccord majeurs sur
le fond avec le gouvernement il reste
même chers collègues une certaine
ambiguïté sur la question des
collectivités locales avec la
suppression de l'article 23 mais en
maintenant l'objectif de baisse des
dépenses des collectivités locales sur
lesquelles vous alignez l'État lui-même
vous comprendrez que nous ne pouvons pas
nous y reconnaître davantage
messieurs monsieur le ministre pardon
monsieur le rapporteur général vous
l'avez compris le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains ne soutiendra
pas ce texte ni dans sa version
gouvernementale ni dans sa version
senatoriale nous avons des propositions
à faire de justice fiscale
je les ai faites tout à l'heure j'ai
entendu que Bruno Le Maire disait
aidez-moi pour faire de la justice
fiscale j'ai considéré que c'était pas
de l'humour et que nous essayons mais
enfin il faut quand même nous aider à
vous aider plutôt que d'appeler
simplement à la rescousse ce côté là de
l'hémicycle nous nous soutiendrons pas
ce texte puisque cette effort de justice
fiscale n'a pas été fait aussi parce
qu'il est trop fragile dans ses
hypothèses parce qu'il est contestable
de notre point de vue dans ses
orientations et des logis idéologiques
déséquilibré dans la répartition de
l'effort inapte à répondre aux besoins
du pays en matière sociale et écologique
dans les prochaines années et risquez
aussi il faut le dire quand on connaît
le mécontentement social qui couvre dans
notre pays face aux face aux injustices
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à présent à Monsieur
Jérémy Baki pour le groupe communiste
vous avez 5 minutes chers
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues nous
venons d'apprendre le déclenchement de
nouveaux 49-3 par la première ministre
la première année de la programmation
aura donc été enjambée par le
gouvernement et nous continuons de
débattre comme si de rien n'était ici au
Sénat j'aurais aimé vous dire que j'ai
accueilli ce projet de loi de
programmation de finance publique avec
enthousiasme tant qu'il aurait répondu à
l'urgence dans laquelle se trouve le
pays mais il n'en est rien j'aurais aimé
à minima pouvoir dire que ce projet de
loi de programmation des finances
publiques comprenait la gravité de ce
qui traverse la vie de nos concitoyens
et de nos concitoyens mais une fois de
plus il n'en est rien en réalité vous
avez choisi de verrouiller l'ensemble
des échelons de la puissance publique
l'ensemble des partis prenantes des
politiques publiques au service de nos
concitoyens et concitoyens dans ce
projet de loi de programmation alors que
les Françaises et les Français sont de
plus en plus nombreuses et nombreux à ne
pas savoir comment ils vont chauffer cet
hiver alors que les Françaises et les
Français voient leur pouvoir d'achat
fondre comme neige au soleil sous
l'effet de l'inflation galopante alors
que les Françaises et les Français
toujours plus nombreuses et nombreux se
demandent s'ils vont pouvoir trouver un
emploi ou conserver le leur votre seul
réponse c'est la réforme la
Contre-Réforme plutôt celle des
retraites du RSA de l'assurance chômage
à croire que vous ne voulez pas entendre
le sentiment d'injustice et le vent de
révolte qui souffle dans le pays il y a
à peine 6 mois le président de la
République était élu grâce à l'ensemble
des républicains de ce pays dont des
millions de voix issus des rangs de la
gauche ce vote m'oblige disait-il au
soir du second tour renchérissant par
une formule déjà datée je le cite je
sais que nombre de compatriotes ont voté
pour moi non pour soutenir les idées que
je porte mais pour faire barrage à celle
de l'extrême droite fin de citation ce
projet de loi de programmation constitue
un projet exclusion de ces électrices
ces électeurs qui l'ont porté au pouvoir
je viens à présent au projet de loi en
tant que tel dans le rapport annexé à
l'article premier de ce projet de loi la
capacité productive qui sous-entend la
croissance serait je cite soutenu par
les réformes du gouvernement ces
dernières contribueraient notamment
accroître l'offre de travail et parvenir
au plein emploi à l'horizon 2027 il
s'agit en particulier de la réforme des
retraites de la réforme du RSA de la
réforme du contrat cyclicité de
l'assurance chômage fin de citation le
mot est lâcher plein emploi mais bien
loin d'un monde idéal il s'agit d'un
plein emploi hypothétique bâti non pas
sur les besoins et la croissance mais
sur la précarité et un salariat corps
viable à merci avec toujours moins de
droit d'ailleurs le Haut Conseil des
finances publiques dans son avis sur le
projet de loi de programmation ne dit
pas autre chose de votre tautologie sur
l'hypothèse de je cite la croissance
potentielle est optimiste notamment
parce que cette dernière suppose des
effets immédiat de réformes du revenu de
solidarité active des retraites de
l'assurance chômage de l'apprentissage
dont ni les modalités ni les impacts ni
le calendrier ne sont documentés fin de
citation la réforme des retraites en
voulu par votre gouvernement ni le
faites que le taux d'emploi des
sexagénaires et le troisième pire de
l'Union européenne seul un tiers des
60-64 ans est en emploi ils sont
considérés comme musées trop vieux par
un patronat qui délaisse ceux qui ne
correspondent plus aux normes ces
travailleurs extrêmement qualifiés sont
en réalité trop cher trop cher par
rapport aux jeunes d'abord en réalité
main d'oeuvre peu qualifier mais surtout
peu néreuse le niveau des salaires et
votre question tabou qu'elle devrait
être une question alors qu'elle devrait
être pardon une question politique
fondamentale de la décennie qui vient
depuis le début des années 80 la part de
la rémunération salariale dans la valeur
ajoutée a chuté de 8 points dans le pays
ce à quoi il faut ajouter les inégalités
salariales dans le secteur privé qui
augmente d'au moins 5 points des
dizaines de milliards d'euros en salaire
et en cotisations qui rend relativement
insignifiant les économies de d'une
dizaine de milliards d'euros générés par
le report de l'âge légal de la retraite
nous revendiquons en plus de
l'augmentation des salaires évidemment
le partage du temps de travail comme
principal levier pour financer le
système des retraites il s'agit de
travailler moins longtemps dans la
journée dans la semaine et dans la vie
pour que toutes et tous puissions
travailler pour que les conditions de
vie et de dignité soit restaurée je veux
avoir ici un mot pour ces femmes ces
hommes totalement absents de ce projet
de loi de programmation et sans qui
pourtant la France ne tournerait pas ce
sont des métiers pour lesquels les
politiques publiques qu'ils font qu'ils
accompagnent qu'ils portent verront leur
budget baisser dans les trois prochaines
années les enseignants les bénévoles
d'associations les aides-soignantes les
agents territoriaux les travailleurs
sociaux sont autant de professions été
utile que mépriser par cette
programmation les exonérations
absolument massives et cotisations
sociales elles qui ne représentent
aujourd'hui plus que 50% des recettes de
la sécurité sociale comme 82% en 93
c'est toutes ces choses toutes choses
étant égales par ailleurs une paire de
100 milliards d'euros qui échappe au
travailleur je conclus d'une citation
madame la Présidente celle d'Ambroise
Croizat perdent la sécurité sociale qui
disait vivre sans l'angoisse du
lendemain de la maladie ou de l'accident
de travail en cotisant selon ses moyens
et en recevant selon ses besoins voilà
où se trouve le véritable courage bien
loin des logis costériculaires qui
prévalent aujourd'hui mais n'est pas
Ambroise croisant qui le veut merci
merci la parole est à présent à notre
collègue Michel Canevet pour le groupe
Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
4 minutes chers collègues merci merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
chers collègues c'est un exercice assez
ambitieux auquel nous nous appelons
maintenant ambitieux parce que lorsqu'il
s'agit de prévoir l'évolution des
finances publiques pour une période
quinquennale bien entendu ça reste
extrêmement difficile on le voit on le
mesure monsieur le ministre parce que ce
n'est pas la première fois que l'on
procède à cet exercice on l'a déjà fait
en 2009 puis en 2012 puis en 2014 puis
en 2017
qu'observe-t-on lorsqu'on l'a fait
antérieurement et bien tout simplement
c'est qu'en fin de période quinquennale
le résultat est fondamentalement
différent de celui auquel on s'attendait
rappelons-nous sur les trois premières
lois de programmation des finances
publiques c'était à peu près 3% de PIB
de niveau différent de celui que nous
pensions atteindre dans l'objectif que
science-fiction et puis pour celles de
2017 on était à 5,6% d'écart l'année
dernière par rapport à l'objectif quand
c'était fixé c'est dire c'est dire que
cet exercice est particulièrement
ambitieux pourtant il est légitime que
nous nous fixions un CAP en Bretagne on
dit régulièrement que tous les marins
doivent fixer un cap et bien il faut
aussi que qu'on puisse le faire pour nos
finances publiques alors nous les
membres du groupe de l'Union centriste
nous sommes attachés à un certain nombre
de d'objectifs de préoccupation une
première préoccupation qui porte bien
entendu sur la question de la maîtrise
des dépenses publiques c'est quelque
chose qui est absolument essentiel si
l'on veut aller assez loin nous sommes
également attachés à ce que il y est un
traitement
identique entre les collectivités
territoriales et puis l'état il n'y a
pas de raison que
seuls les collectivités territoriales
par exemple soit astreinte métaphore et
que l'État s'en exerneur on a plutôt le
sentiment nous que celui qui donne des
orientations d'habitude il faut qu'il
montre le cap et qu'il montre l'exemple
et donc ça c'est important et puis une
troisième préoccupation porte sur la
question de l'antennement public et pour
nous c'est un vrai sujet de
préoccupation alors quand on a fait ces
constats et bien il y a un certain
nombre de choses auxquelles il faut que
l'on récolte qu'il faut que l'on réalise
bien sûr cette maîtrise des dépenses
publiques nous ne pensons que l'objectif
à la fin du la période quinquennale doit
être autant que possible de se
rapprocher de l'équilibre des finances
publiques alors c'est un exercice
difficile parce qu'il est toujours
difficile d'économiser de ne pas
dépenser plus que ce qu'on a mais c'est
quand même un objectif que l'on devrait
se fixer et puis pour cela il y a d'une
part la question de la maîtrise des
dépenses mais aussi la question des
recettes et on le voit bien
pour ce qui concerne les recettes nous
nous sommes d'accord avec stadie le
ministre le maire tout à l'heure il y a
effectivement un niveau de prélèvement
obligatoire dans notre pays qui est trop
élevé donc il faut que on le diminue
mais il faut qu'on soit attentif à ce
que les priorités soient données vers ce
qui est vraiment productif et force est
de reconnaître puisque nous sommes à cet
automne au moment où on aurait dû payer
la contribution à l'audiovisuel public
que de supprimer cette contribution ne
fut pas pour nous la meilleure des
choses à faire tout simplement parce que
il eut mieux valu que l'effort porta sur
la CVAE par exemple et si on n'avait pas
procédé assis nous pourrions
effectivement soutenir une réduction
significative de la CVAE mais la
prudence nous conduirait à justement se
dire puisque l'effort apporté sur
la contribution de le public il faut
attendre sans doute pour la CVAE et puis
il y a pour les collectivités je les dis
tout à l'heure la nécessité
de ne pas leur demander un effort
supérieur à celui qui est réalisé par
l'État pour nous il est important que
l'effort soit partagé les collectivités
sont en général très vertueux cela a été
dit avant moi il faut que l'État le soir
le plus possible alors on proposera en
ce sens notamment je proposerai un
amendement pour le FCTV je vois que mon
père donc je vais m'arrêter en tout cas
le groupe de l'Union centriste votera le
projet présenté par le rapporteur
général merci chers collègues la parole
est à présent à notre collègue monsieur
Gérard Longuet pour le groupe des
Républicains
[Applaudissements]
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues mon
excellent collègue Michel canvet a
rappelé que beaucoup des lois de
programmation n'avaient pas été confirmé
et quand on va au résultat il y a un
écart
la vérité c'est que cet exercice est
utile mais qu'il n'est pas suffisant et
mon excellente collègue elle aussi
excellente Michel lava Christine
lavardde m'a renvoyé le bébé en disant
mais c'est très simple puisque nous
sommes d'accord pour pas nous battre sur
les paramètres parce que c'est un débat
qui n'en finit plus nous avons
l'intention d'étudier votre projet de
loi de la mandée et de le voter c'est
parfait mais avec évidemment ces
préoccupations qui viennent d'être les
Cavés rappelés notre notre très bon
rapporteur général Jean-François Husson
faire en sorte que les efforts soient
partagés puisque si on ne se bat pas sur
les paramètres au moins reconnaissons
qu'il y ait à un effort d'équilibre dans
les
forces d'équilibre pour les différents
acteurs les appuies
administration publique centrale
évidemment les collectivités locales et
le social alors la question 25 milliards
vous trouvez ça beaucoup car en bout de
parcours on arrive en effet à 25
milliards alors comme j'ai peu de temps
je vais vous dire l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est que premièrement sur
le marché du travail vous avez 6 mesures
de réforme qui sont intéressantes les
retraites évidemment le RSA
l'indemnisation du chômage vous avez
également prévu l'apprentissage Pôle
emploi et important pour les jeunes
ménage là jeunes enfants le contrat
jeune enfant petite enfance pardon et
bien sachez simplement que et je crois
que Bruno le merle a évoqué passé de 7
et demi à 5 c'est bien mais sachez que
de 15 à 54 à 64 ans seul
71,9% des Français sont actifs
c'est-à-dire un emploi ou donne ou
demandeur d'emploi il y a donc alors que
ce chiffre est de 79 en Allemagne de 80%
au Pays-Bas si nous regagnons une partie
de ces 8 points d'écart avec ces mesures
là on dégage de l'argent dégage de la
marge parce qu'évidemment des gens qui
travaillent ça rapporte et ça rapporte à
tout le monde et notamment à l'état le
deuxième sujet c'est naturellement
l'énergie et alors là il y a qu'une
seule solution arriver à obtenir de
l'Union européenne qu'elle cesse de un
marché unique où l'on met sur le même
plan l'électron fossile et l'électron
décarbonés et c'est la bataille
essentielle que votre gouvernement doit
livrer parce que si nous avons un
électron décarboné vous allez pouvoir
mettre fin à une machine une espèce
d'usine d'une complexité effrayante qui
consiste à aider les uns parce que la
taxe carbone parce que
la volonté de faire des énergies
renouvelables qui ne soit pas nucléaires
non
séparer les deux et il y aura un
électron décarboné et à ce moment-là les
investisseurs n'auront pas besoin de
subventions pour pour investir parce
qu'ils auront des éléments fixes en
effet l'électron décarboné à une
particularité c'est qu'il n'est pas
sensible
aux éléments extérieurs alors que
l'électron carboné
issus du fossile est totalement
dépendant de marché internationaux et
naturellement des relations monétaires
ça c'était la deuxième idée la troisième
idée c'est de tenir compte simplement de
la démographie il y a hélas dans notre
pays une diminution de 10% des classes
d'âge et là je le poserai demain en
commission des finances une épreuve de
vérité pour un certain nombre
d'administrations et au premier rang
d'entre elles l'éducation nationale nous
ne pouvons on doit faire du qualitatif
parce que nos jeunes ne sont pas assez
formés les classements internationaux
sont sévères pour nous mais on devrait
plus faire de quantitatif et c'est un
vrai sujet et cela peut dégager des
marches sur le premier budget civil de
l'État 60 milliards d'euros si on ne
gagne pas un peu pour nourrir les 25 en
fin de parcours c'est que vraiment n'est
pas bon
quatrième et dernière proposition
d'économie
à la productivité du service public une
chose que je ne comprends pas le même
président avec le même enthousiasme en
2017 proposait moins 50 000 emplois
publics en 5 ans
et là il réélu ben non il y a plus rien
comme si il n'y avait plus de
productivité possible vous êtes dans un
ministère qui pratique la productivité
et vous avez certainement de toutes les
administrations centrales de l'État vous
êtes à la tête d'une administration qui
a su à la fois maintenir un service et
adapter les effectifs sans trahir les
administrés et bien je crois que il faut
reprendre cette question de la
productivité du service public ce n'est
pas injurieux ce n'est pas déshonorant
il y a des façons différentes de
travailler et nous devons entrer dans le
détail les ministères doivent être
dirigés par des ministres qui ont le
souci de la réalité de l'efficacité en
revanche une question
nous avons cette loi de programmation et
on annonce une loi de progression
militaire l'ancien ministre de la
Défense que je suis se félicite de
l'intérêt
mais s'interroge le membre de la
commission des finances s'interroge sur
la compatibilité de l'un et de l'autre
puisque les sommes avancées sont
spectaculaires la situation
internationale peut l'expliquer mais il
serait intéressant que vous assuriez une
coordination dans la même semaine entre
les efforts d'économie et les annonces
de dépenses le débat parlementaire y
gagnerait en clarté
Maxime
la parole est enfin au Président
Monsieur Vincent Delahaye pour le groupe
Union centriste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
en général j'aime l'optimisme
mais en matière de gestion de l'argent
public je pense que l'optimisme est
souvent dangereux
pour bien gérer l'argent public il faut
être rigoureux et prudent
vos prévisions de croissance monsieur le
ministre sont très optimistes elles sont
très supérieures à ce que l'on a
constaté sur la les deux dernières
décennies et à ce que prévoit le
consensus des économistes
je pense que ce n'est pas prudent bien
sûr ça gonfle artificiellement les
recettes futures mais ça n'est pas
prudent vos prévisions ne sont pas
sincères vous mélangez les dépenses
courantes et les dépenses
exceptionnelles qui sont liées à vos
choix de gestion de la crise sanitaire
et de la crise énergétique
je vous avais pourtant demandé monsieur
le ministre en commission des finances
de bien vouloir distinguer à partir de
2023 et pour les années suivantes ce qui
était du courant de l'exceptionnel et là
vous mélangez tout allègrement et vous
faites croire que la dépense publique
baisse alors qu'en fait ce sont que les
dépenses exceptionnelles qui baissent et
que les dépenses courantes elles
augmentent de façon importante donc pour
moi elles ne sont pas sincères ces
dépenses en plus elles ne sont pas
justes vos prévisions de sont pas justes
parce que en réalité vous demandez un
effort aux collectivités territoriales
que vous n'apposez pas à l'état et quand
on regarde les dépenses courantes les
dépenses courantes augmentent fortement
et les dépenses des ministères
augmentent aussi fortement donc nous
aimerions bien que l'État s'impose le
même effort que celui qu'il demande aux
collectivités ça ça serait juste
et puis ensuite vos prévisions pour moi
ne préparent pas bien l'avenir quel est
le problème numéro un de notre pays
aujourd'hui c'est de produire le plus
vite possible un maximum d'énergie
décarbonée je pense qu'on peut se mettre
d'accord là-dessus on nous annonce des
coupures cet hiver on sait que pour
l'industrie c'est indispensable pour
notre compétitivité c'est indispensable
pour nos concitoyens c'est
indispensables donc il faut en produire
le plus vite possible pour moi il
faudrait un véritable plan Marshall de
l'énergie aujourd'hui et dans vos
prévisions il n'y a quasiment rien
quasiment rien pour les cinq prochaines
années sur ce sujet moi je suis effaré
donc
pas prudent pas sincère pas juste
préparant mal l'avenir comme vous voulez
vous qu'on accepte votre programmation
financière alors heureusement je salue
le travail du rapporteur général et de
la commission des finances heureusement
nous allons profondément modifier ce
texte c'est une chance mais ma
conviction reste la même on fonce dans
le mur et on accélère encore pour moi
c'est suicidaire
donc monsieur le ministre je pense qu'il
est grand grand temps de changer de
politique budgétaire et pour cela je
vous ai apporté un cadeau que je vais
vous remettre un livre sur les vertus de
l'équilibre ou l'anti quoi qu'il en
coûte je pense que sa lecture vous sera
utile c'est un très bon auteur merci
Gérard Longuet et je pense vraiment que
vous verrez à travers ce livre que les
pays dont les économistes se portent
mieux que la nôtre et il y en a quand
même à quelques-uns toutes ces économies
toutes ces pays ont des finances saines
donc je pense qu'il est grand temps de
reprendre cette ligne et de la suivre
pour les années prochaines voilà
merci de m'avoir écouté merci chers
collègues
la discussion générale est close je vous
laisse remettre le livre au ministre
mais je vais donner l'apparence au
ministre pour
répondre
monsieur le ministre si vous voulez
répondre aux différentes interpellations
pardon madame la Présidente on hésitait
à demander une subvention de séance pour
que je puisse lire le livre avant de
vous répondre mais je le lirai un peu
plus tard dans la soirée en tout cas
merci à tous les orateurs qui se sont
exprimés c'est un beau débat c'est un
débat riche que nous avons commencé à
voir et que nous allons continuer à
avoir moi ce que je veux retenir d'abord
c'est que j'ai entendu une majorité
d'orateurs
reconnaître en tout cas s'inscrire dans
un objectif
d'assainissement de nos finances
publiques et de retour à une trajectoire
plus maîtrisée d'équilibre c'est d'abord
ça que je veux reconnaître ensuite il y
a un débat effectivement sur le rythme
c'est vrai que nous prévoyons un rythme
de retour à sous les 3% à horizon 2027
c'est ce que nous avions annoncé pendant
la campagne présidentielle stabilisation
de la dette en 206 retour sous les 3% en
2027 plusieurs orateurs parmi vous
c'était notamment le cas de du sénateur
Capus c'était le cas également d'autres
sénateurs ont insisté sur le fait que ce
rythme nous plaçait alors madame lavard
je crois parler de mauvais élève en tout
cas en queue de peloton dans le
calendrier tel que les différents
programmes de stabilité pacte stabilité
ont annoncé un retour sous les trois
pour cent c'est vrai c'est vrai que les
derniers pays européens avant nous et
notamment l'Espagne annonce un retour
sous les 3% à horizon 2025 là où nous
prévoyons un retour sur les 3% à horizon
2027 il faudra voir quand même au moment
de la présentation des prochains
testables si ces trajectoires sont
toujours les mêmes nous avons l'occasion
à plusieurs reprises de Ré utiliser nos
prévisions avec notamment la
présentation des PLF et autres je suis
pas sûr que ça soit le cas dans tous les
pays et j'ai noté qu'un certain nombre
de pays après avoir présenté leur
programme de stabilité ont annoncé un
certain nombre de mesures pour lutter
contre l'inflation de boucliers
tarifaires il faudra voir si ils
prévoient toujours le même calendrier de
retour sous les trois pour cent mais de
toute façon nous assumons nous assumons
de dire que plutôt qu'une politique
brutale d'austérité budgétaire nous
préférons un retour maîtrisé planifier
sous les 3% qui tirent les enseignements
aussi de certaines politiques qui ont
été menées dans d'autres crises par le
passé notamment après la crise 2008 2010
ou à vouloir établir trop brutalement et
trop rapidement les finances publiques
on finit par casser la dynamique de
croissance et une Phinée à créer du
chômage en plus et donc des recettes en
moins pour les finances publiques et
donc des déficits et une dette qui
s'accroît on assume de dire qu'on veut
que le retour sous les 3% et le
rétablissement de nos comptes publics
soient compatibles avec l'activité
économique
on a vu en 2021 qu'on avait une
croissance locomotive en Europe on voit
en 2022 qu'on a une croissance qui
résiste et qu'on a une économie qui
résiste remarquablement madame l'avare
de la cité les trois dimensions
importantes consommation investissement
commerce extérieur vous n'êtes pas
beaucoup attardé sur l'investissement je
pense pour ne pas relever le fait et
Céline c'est qu'il a salué que
l'investissement repart continuer à
progresser assez nettement au dernier
être trimestre 2,8% dans notre pays ce
qui est un signe positif encore une fois
je dis pas ça pour le mettre au crédit
du gouvernement je le mets au crédit de
toutes les femmes et tous les hommes qui
investissent et qui entreprennent dans
notre pays et qui permettent à notre
économie de tenir qui permettent
d'embaucher des Français d'investir de
stimuler l'activité économique et donc
les recettes pour notre pays parce que
oui monsieur Ferro nous avons assumé de
baisser la pression fiscale sur les
entreprises mais nous collectons
davantage de recettes fiscales venant
des entreprises depuis que nous avons
baissé les taux nous avons passé l'impôt
sur les sociétés de 33% à 25% c'est 5
dernières années on collecte plus
d'impôts pour les sociétés à 25% qu'on
en collecté à 33%. on est en train de
faire la démonstration que quand vous
taxez moins un gâteau qui grossit vous
gagnez plus que quand vous surtaxez un
gâteau qui se rétrécit parce que vous le
surtaxez c'est ça qu'on est en train de
démontrer donc oui nous assumons de
vouloir continuer à baisser la pression
fiscale qui pèse sur l'activité
économique c'est aussi ce qui permet
l'activité économique de continuer à se
développer et infiner qui nous permet
d'obtenir des recettes supplémentaires
alors on voit il y a une proposition
d'une autre ligne qui est défendue par
la majorité sénatoriale qui est de dire
allons beaucoup plus vite dans le
rétablissement des comptes beaucoup plus
vite dans le rétablissement des comptes
c'est à dire autour sur les 3% 2 ans
avant j'ai entendu madame l'avare
défendre cette trajectoire
je redis cette trajectoire elle implique
25 milliards d'économies supplémentaires
à trouver n'ont pas enfin de période
monsieur longuet mais en 2025 il se
trouve qu'il y a dans cette loi de
programmation des finances publiques à
l'article 12 la programmation des
missions budgétaires de l'État à horizon
2025 et donc je pense qu'en toute
cohérence puisque vous défendez 25
milliards d'économies en plus à horizon
2025 que vous pourriez amender cet
article pour dire où vous prenez les 25
milliards d'économies est-ce que c'est
sur la défense est-ce que c'est sur
l'éducation nationale est-ce que c'est
sur la transition écologique j'ai
entendu les propositions qui ont été
faites et moi je le dis vraiment moi je
suis favorable à ce qu'on fasse le plus
d'économies possible et j'ai dit en
entrée de ses débats que si on ressort
de l'examen de cette LPFP dans les
différentes lectures dans les
différentes chambres qu'on ressort avec
un compromis qui conduit à ce que l'État
réhaus le niveau d'effort prévu par
rapport à ce qu'on avait proposé dans le
texte initial mais j'en serai le premier
ravi et je pense juste qu'il faut que ce
soit crédible et soutenable par rapport
à ce qu'on est capable de faire
bien entendu les pistes que vous avez
évoquées monsieur Longuet oui évidemment
que la réforme des retraites la réforme
du RSA la réforme de l'assurance chômage
la réforme de Pôle Emploi le service
public de la petite enfance ont vocation
à nous permettre de rétablir nos
finances publiques parce que pour
certaines pour certaines de ces réformes
elles permettent des économies
budgétaires directes la réforme des
retraites par exemple pour d'autres en
tout cas pour la totalité d'entre elles
elles permettent d'élargir le marché du
travail le taux d'emploi dans notre pays
et donc des recettes supplémentaires
mais elles sont intégrées dans la
programmation des finances publiques
dans le texte du Gouvernement ça nous
est d'ailleurs reproché régulièrement
par la partie gauche de cette hémicycle
ou de celui de l'assemblée qui nous dit
régulièrement vous intégrer dans votre
trajectoire les bénéfices de réforme qui
n'ont pas encore été adoptés notamment
sur la réforme des retraites mais tout
ça est déjà intégré dans la trajectoire
et donc les économies supplémentaires ou
les recettes fiscales supplémentaires
que vous appelez de vos vœux elles
doivent être trouvées par d'autres
réformes que celle-ci qui sont d'ores et
déjà intégrées mais je vous rejoins
totalement sur le fait que si on avait
le même taux d'emploi que nos voisins
allemands j'aurais beaucoup moins de
travail et on se poserait beaucoup moins
la question de savoir comment est-ce
qu'on équilibre nos finances publiques
si on avait 8 à 10 points de plus en
taux d'emploi dans notre pays évidemment
que la question des finances publiques
se poserait dans des termes bien
différents parce qu'on aurait des
recettes supplémentaires et qu'on
équilibrerait davantage
la réforme des retraites elle vise à
améliorer le taux d'emploi la réforme de
la formation professionnelle la réforme
de l'apprentissage la réforme du lycée
professionnel qu'on engage elle vise
aussi améliorer le taux d'emploi
notamment chez les jeunes générations ça
vise à faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus
de français au travail dans notre pays
donc plus de recettes pour les finances
publiques pour la sécurité sociale sur
la question de la décorrélation pris de
l'électricité près du gaz on est
totalement aligné avec ce que vous
appelez de vos beux on veut on mène ce
combat au niveau européen c'est pas
facile mais je crois qu'on progresse je
suis pas immédiatement en charge de ce
dossier là j'écoute ce que me disent mes
collègues Bruno Le Maire et Agnès
panière une haché je crois qu'on
progresse de ce point de vue là et que
le dernier Conseil européen a permis
quand même de dessiner certaines
avancées notamment dans un premier temps
un plafonnement du prix du gaz utilisé
pour produire de l'électricité ce qui
serait quand même une première marche
importante et particulièrement
utile sur la démographie oui il faut en
tenir compte on en tient compte dans la
programmation c'est vrai qu'il va y
avoir 500 000 élèves de moins dans
l'éducation nationale dans les 5 ans qui
viennent 500 000 élèves de on a connu
ces dernières années une un boom
démographie on les on arrive là dans le
creux de la vague donc 500 000 élèves de
moins dans l'éducation nationale on veut
maintenir et même continuer à améliorer
le taux d'encadrement pour nos élèves je
pense que pour le coup dans tous les
départements c'est quelque chose qui
revient beaucoup dans toutes les
circonscriptions c'est demander quand
même de pouvoir garder un taux
d'encadrement
important pour les élèves mais tout en
faisant ça évidemment que il y a un
certain nombre de marches qui sont
retrouvés c'est intégrés dans la
trajectoire que nous avons
proposé sur la productivité du service
public comme vous l'avez appelé ou la
réduction du nombre de fonctionnaires
c'est vrai je l'assume qu'il y a eu pour
le coup un changement de logique par
rapport à 2017 c'est vrai qu'en 2017 je
me souviens j'ai fait la campagne
d'Emmanuel Macron et s'est engagé sur un
objectif avec un nombre de fonctions de
postes de fonctionnaires qui seraient
supprimé dans le quinquennat et puis on
a assumé après la crise des gilets
jaunes de dire que nous n'avions plus
d'objectifs de nombres de suppression à
atteindre mais que nous devions engager
des réformes qui permettraient ensuite
de dégager des marges de poste de
fonctionnaires le prélèvement à la
source ça a été ça la suppression d'un
certain nombre d'impôts nous permet
aussi de trouver des marges mon
ministère celui de Bercy je crois que
c'est 4 ou 6% de l'emploi public c'est
80% des efforts de réduction de l'emploi
public ces 10 dernières années donc on
sait ce que de faire des efforts en
matière d'emploi public mais on le fait
après des réformes de modernisation qui
permettent de dégager ces marges et
c'est vrai qu'en 2022 le président de la
République ne sait pas engagé sur un
nombre de postes de fonctionnaires à
supprimer il y a une candidate et en
l'occurrence la candidate DLR qui s'y
est engagée mais sans vraiment dire à
mon sens où est-ce que ces postes
seraient retirés mais le président de la
République s'est engagé au contraire moi
c'est le mandat qui m'a été donné à une
stabilité de l'emploi public sur le
quinquennat il y a un certain nombre de
créations importantes qui sont prévues
en 2023 notamment dans le secteur
régalien le mandat qui nous a été
confiée c'est stabilité de l'emploi
public sur le quinquennat ce qui veut
pas dire qu'on bouge pas on va créer
8500 postes dans la justice 8500 postes
de policiers et de gendarmes ça veut
dire pour atteindre une stabilité qu'il
faut en supprimer ailleurs et donc cet
effort là va être fait mais notre
logique c'est plutôt d'avoir des postes
davantage dans les territoires
déconcentrés des administrations
centrales donc moi j'entends qu'il y a
des efforts qui peuvent être faits en la
matière
si je schématisais un calcul 10000
postes de fonctionnaires c'est 500
millions d'euros donc si on veut
atteindre des montants d'économie tels
que ceux que vous évoquez ça fait
beaucoup de passes de fonctionnaires à
supprimer en net pour le coup donc je
suis pas sûr que ça soit suffisant mais
il faut évidemment tout tout regarder je
voulais dire un mot sur la question des
prévisions qui sont prévues dans ce
texte c'est évidemment toujours
difficile à la prévision c'est un art
qui fait l'objet de controverse voilà
mais de toute façon on peut discuter
longtemps des prévisions vous me direz
qu'elles sont trop optimistes trop
ambitieuses moi je vous dirais qu'elles
sont réalistes étayées mais à la fin ce
qui fait la croissance telle qu'elle se
réalise c'est ni les prévisions ni les
politiques ou les experts qui en
débattent l'année précédente c'est la
confiance pour notre secteur économique
pour nos entreprises qui sont capables
d'investir de produire et d'embaucher et
ce dont je suis absolument sûr c'est que
les prévisions de croissance que nous
portons aussi optimiste ou volontariste
soient-elles ne se réaliseront pas si
nous ne poursuivons pas dans notre
politique pour redonner des marges à nos
entreprises pour qu'elles puissent
investir produire et recruter d'où la
suppression de la CVE qui est prévue
dans le PLF qui est extrêmement
importante d'où la poursuite de nos
mesures en faveur de l'emploi de la
formation et de la compétitivité de nos
entreprises je crois que j'ai fait le
tour peut-être un mot sur les
collectivités locales on aura l'occasion
d'y revenir au moment des discussions
sur l'article 16 sur l'article 23 il me
semble moi je suis tout à fait favorable
à ce qu'il y ait dans la discussion
parlementaire un rééquilibrage un plus
grand équilibre dans l'effort demandé à
l'état par rapport aux collectivités
locales dans le texte du Gouvernement il
est prévu une baisse de 0,4 % pour
l'État en volume sur le quinquennat de
0.5% pour les collectivités en volume
sur le quinquennat vous avez proposé une
première chose c'est dire on fait 0,5
pour l'État 05 pour les collectivités
locales moi je suis très ouvert à ça ça
nécessite un effort supplémentaire pour
l'État mais je pense qu'on doit être
capable de l'assumer mais ce que vous
dites aussi et c'est ça ou ce qui
implique de trouver 25 milliards d'euros
c'est que l'effort des dépenses de
maîtriser dépenses de l'État doit se
faire sur des dépenses qui ne concernent
pas la relance ou la crise on demande
pas la même chose aux collectivités
locales dans la copie
qui pour qui elle les dépenses relatives
à la crise et à la relance sont prises
en compte dans le calcul et donc
derrière un apparent équilibre entre
l'État et les collectivités locales il y
a en effet un très grand déséquilibre
puisque ça veut dire que les dépenses de
l'État sur les 5 années qui viennent
dans la copie qui est proposé par la
Commission des finances augmenteront de
1,5% en valeur la loi augmenteront de
10% en valeur pour les collectivités
locales ça veut dire par ailleurs qu'il
faut trouver je le redis 25 milliards
horizons 2025 37 milliards à horizon
il s'agit pas encore une fois de dire
qu'on va imposer une austérité aux
collectivités locales ça on a vu ce que
c'était sous le quinquennat Hollande
avec les baisses brutales de DGF j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure monsieur broyeur
dire vous allez baisser les dépenses de
fonctionnement des collectivités non
dans la copie telle qu'elle est
présentée par le gouvernement dans LPFP
les dépenses de fonctionnement des
collectivités locales elles augmentent
de 21 milliards d'euros sur les 5 années
qui viennent elles augmentent de 21
milliards d'euros il s'agit pas de dire
qu'elle baisse elles vont continuer à
progresser dans la copie que nous avons
proposé simplement nous mettons un cadre
pour l'État et pour les collectivités
locales de maîtrise dans la durée et
vous appelez à soutenir vous avez dit
vous devriez soutenir les collectivités
locales enfin nous on n'a pas fait des
baisses brutales de DGF massives comme
ça a été le cas sous le quinquennat de
François Hollande et à l'époque les
écologistes faisaient partie de la
majorité de François Hollande on a
sanctuarisé la DGF depuis cinq ans alors
on la sanctuarisé au niveau global et
c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de mères
qui viennent ensuite vous voir et qui
vous disent vous dites que vous avez
sanctuarisé mais moi ma DGF a baissé il
faut que je suis parti des quelques
membres du gouvernement qui sont élus
locaux j'ai pas eu la chance ou
l'honneur d'être Homer je ne suis un
modeste conseiller municipal depuis près
de 10 ans et c'est vrai que j'ai pu voir
que moi dans ma commune quand bien même
nous avons sanctuarisé la DGF depuis 5
ans la DGF a légèrement baissé du fait
de la prééquation précisément ce que
nous proposons dans le PLF pour 2023
c'est historique c'est 320 millions
d'euros en plus pour neutraliser les
effets de la péréquation ce qui veut
dire qu'en 2023 pour la première fois
depuis 13 ans la DGF de 95% des communes
augmentera 95% des communes c'est inédit
et historique pendant la crise sanitaire
il y a eu 10 milliards d'euros de
transferts de l'État aux collectivité
locale ces cinq dernières années les
concours financiers de l'État aux
collectivité locale ont augmenté de 5
milliards d'euros franchement on a vu
plus grande maltraitance des
collectivités locales que ces cinq
dernières années il faut avoir
l'honnêteté quand même de le dire et
j'entends les comparaisons sur le
déficit de l'État par rapport à celui
des collectivités locales qui ne font
pas de déficit qui représente une part
de qui est plus faible mais enfin le
déficit de l'État la dette de l'État qui
s'est accrue au moment du quoi qu'il en
coûte
il a aussi permis aux collectivités
locales d'avoir moins de dépenses à
effectuer quand on fait le quoi qu'il en
coûte on évite à des centaines de
milliers d'entreprises de se casser la
figure et donc à des dépenses sociales
pour les collectivités locales si on
avait retrouvé des millions de Français
plongés dans la précarité des dépenses
sociales tu auras explosé pour les
collectivités locales donc
l'investissement du quoi qu'il en coûte
oui qui a alourdi le déficit de l'État
et la dette de l'État mais c'est aussi
un investissement qui a évité des
dépenses pour les collectivités locales
et on l'assume totalement parce que
notre conviction c'est qu'il ne faut pas
opposer l'État et les collectivités
locales comme s'il y avait l'un contre
l'autre mais que c'est l'un avec l'autre
et qu'on a les mêmes objectifs a priori
les mêmes intérêts les objectifs et les
intérêts c'est quoi c'est de permettre à
notre pays de continuer à investir on a
besoin d'investir face à la transition
écologique on a besoin d'investir face à
la transition démographique si on veut
avoir les marges de manœuvre pour
investir
est-ce qu'il faut laisser filer les
dépenses se retrouver avec des taux
d'intérêt qui explosent et donc un état
privé de marge de manoeuvre et des
collectivités locales elles-mêmes
privées de marge de manœuvre pour
investir si vous avez les taux d'intérêt
qui explosent non on a plutôt intérêt
état et collectivités locales affronter
le défi de la transition écologique de
la transition énergétique de la
transition démographique numérique en
investissant massivement et pour
investir il faut qu'on ait des marges de
manœuvre et pour avoir des marges de
manoeuvre il faut maîtriser suffisamment
nos dépenses de fonctionnement état et
collectivités locales pour avoir des
taux d'intérêt soutenables pour être
capable d'emprunter pour investir c'est
ça la logique comporte ça n'est rien
d'autre que ça c'est de main dans la
main avec les collectivités locales
d'être capable de bénéficier des marges
de manœuvre suffisantes enfin je voulais
répondre à Monsieur Baki sur la question
des investissements sociaux et notamment
pour un certain nombre de professions
que vous avez saluées qui sont très
engagés dans notre pays vous avez cité
notamment les enseignants et les
aides-soignants en disant qu'ils sont
méprisés
moi je veux quand même rappeler que le
Segur de la santé dans son volet
revalorisation c'est l'augmentation
salariale la plus forte qui a connue
l'hôpital public dans son histoire sur
un ton aussi court c'est près de 200
euros net en plus par mois pour tous
ceux qui travaillent à l'hôpital c'est
10 milliards d'euros d'investissement
pérennisé pour la revalorisation des
salaires pour tous ceux qui travaillent
à l'hôpital vous avez cité les
enseignants dans le projet de loi de
finances pour 2023 on prévoit une
augmentation de 10% pour tous les
enseignants à la rentrée de septembre
2023 j'ai pas souvenir dans un passé
récent ou lointain qu'il y ait eu une
telle augmentation de 10% sur une année
et on prévoit même 25% en plus ça sera
dans les années qui viennent pour des
enseignants qui accepteront de s'engager
dans des missions supplémentaires qui
sont en train d'être définies en
concertation avec les représentants des
enseignants par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale donc je encore une
fois il y a beaucoup de Français qui
sont en difficulté oui il faut continuer
il faut soutenir davantage nos
enseignants mais dire qu'ils sont
maîtrisés quand on a 6 milliards d'euros
de revalorisation salariale pour nos
enseignants 10% dès l'année prochaine
encore une fois ça me semble aussi pas
totalement adapté à la réalité des faits
mais tout ça nous aurons l'occasion dans
des battre aussi à l'occasion du PLF
merci
nous allons commencer la discussion du
texte je vous rappelle que je
suspendrais à 20h que nous avons 74
amendements monsieur Savoldelli vous
avez demandé la parole sur l'article 1er
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur Miss
mais chers collègues
nous on ressent un certain malaise
parce que à l'instant T à l'instant